Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Hier ist UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Fridloff und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 120 von UKW.
Und die wird aufgenommen am 7.
April im Jahre 2024.
Und wenig überraschend ist auch diese Folge eine Folge über die Ukraine.
Und ich begrüße dafür ein weiteres Mal Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau, jetzt ziemlich genau einen Monat, nachdem wir unseren letzten Rundumschlag
gemacht haben, dieses 5 Stunden Brett,
ich verspreche euch, heute wird es nicht so lange dauern, wollen wir nochmal
ein bisschen zusammenfegen,
was so passiert ist und so ein bisschen das gesamte Geschehen rund um den Krieg
in der Ukraine ein bisschen kontextualisieren und ein bisschen erklären,
was so passiert ist und wie man da vielleicht drüber nachdenken sollte.
Insgesamt war es nicht von großen Umbrüchen, sondern eher von einer Fortführung
bestehender Tendenzen geprägt.
Es gab eine Präsidentenwahl in Russland, es gab einen Terroranschlag in Russland
und wieder diverse kleinere Erfolge auf beiden Seiten.
Aber nichts, was jetzt den Konflikt irgendwie komplett in eine andere Richtung geschickt hätte.
Und ich denke so kann man das erstmal ganz gut zusammenfassen und das ist so
das worüber wir reden wollen.
Wir wollen auch ein bisschen noch über die Mobilisierungen in Russland und auch
in der Ukraine sprechen.
Wir wollen ein bisschen über die politische Debatte reden, die sich jetzt so
zwischen USA, Europa, NATO entwickelt hat.
Das ist sehr interessant und ja noch ein paar andere Kleinigkeiten einwerfen.
Ja, so machen wir das. Gut, dann fangen wir doch mal gleich an mit dem militärischen
Update, wie es hier eigentlich immer so üblich ist.
Ist ein bisschen, ja fast schon ein bisschen schwierig zu erklären,
aber im Wesentlichen passiert eigentlich nichts.
Nix grundsätzlich, wenn man jetzt im Detail drauf schaut, ist es so,
dass Russland derzeit auf einem Vormarsch ist, aber dieser Vormarsch fällt sehr, sehr langsam aus.
Das hat einerseits was damit zu tun, dass halt die Ukraine jetzt auch gerade
bei Avtivka sich mal wieder zurück hat ziehen müssen, darüber haben wir ja schon gesprochen.
Aber noch nicht mal die vollständige Fläche, von der sie sich zurückgezogen
haben von den Russen, hat in irgendeiner Form nennenswert erobert werden können.
Das heißt, es ist im Wesentlichen ein übernommener Bereich.
Das bezieht sich eben konkret auf die Stadt Avtivka, beziehungsweise das,
was davon übrig geblieben ist.
Vor allem dieser Industrial Complex, wo natürlich die Russen dann erstmal eingezogen sind.
Aber alles das bis dahin, wo die Ukraine jetzt steht und auch langsam anfängt
starke Befestigungen zu bauen, das machen sie nicht nur dort,
das machen sie generell über die gesamte Frontlinie, hat jetzt die Ukraine angefangen
auch diese Betonpyramiden aufzubauen.
Und im Prinzip genauso wie diese Surowikin-Linie der Russen,
die den Vorstoß der Ukraine verhindern sollte und das ja auch geschafft hat,
genauso was baut jetzt die Ukraine auch.
Das heißt, da werden Gräben aufgebaggert und befestigt und überdacht und mit
so Betoninlets in den Gräben.
Also das ist sozusagen jetzt eine absolute Verteidigungslinie,
die jetzt nicht nur eine Linie auf einer Karte ist, sondern die eben wirklich
auch mit Bauten dafür sorgen soll,
dass es den Russen nicht gelingt über einen bestimmten Punkt hinaus in irgendeiner
Form weiter ins Land einzudringen.
Ansonsten geht es vor allem auch deshalb langsam voran,
weil jetzt eben das Frühjahr angebrochen ist und nach relativ kalten Temperaturen
im März das sich langsam wieder auftaut und das bedeutet dann in der Ukraine,
schon das Wort vergessen, aber halt Das ist Butiza.
Aber matsch eigentlich. Ich würde sagen, es ist matsch, matschig und schlammig.
Genau, also ukrainische Boden hat einfach die Eigenschaft, dann sehr matschig
zu sein und da bleibt dann halt alles stehen.
Mit anderen Worten, Vorstöße sind dann eben auch nur über Straßen möglich.
Im Feld kommt man irgendwie überhaupt nicht voran und auch die Straßen sind
halt teilweise in einem schlimmen Zustand.
Nichtsdestotrotz schicken die Russen immer noch viele Panzer und was nicht alles
nach vorne und das allermeiste davon wird dann aber irgendwie von FPV-Drones,
also von diesen First Person View ferngesteuerten Drohnen mit der Artillerie,
die den Ukrainern verblieben ist und anderen Methoden zerstört.
Also es gibt wenig wirkliche Durchbrüche und das Ganze ist halt weiterhin ein
fieser Kampf mit vielen Verlusten, vor allem mit sehr vielen Verlusten auf der russischen Seite.
Es ist wie immer schwierig konkret zu quantifizieren, aber es macht sehr den
Eindruck, dass insbesondere weil
die Ukraine sich jetzt eben auf so Verteidigungslinien zurückgezogen hat,
dass die Verluste auf der ukrainischen Seite sehr viel geringer sind als auf der russischen Seite.
Ja und die Russen scheinen neulich, also in den letzten Monaten,
irgendwann einen größeren Panzerangriff gestartet zu haben.
Also mit über 40 Fahrzeugen, zehn davon Kampfpanzer.
Und der ist wohl genauso übel geendet, wie als die Ukrainer dasselbe probiert
haben letztes Jahr im Sommer halt.
Und das war in der Nähe von Avdivka auch und die Russen dachten,
dass sie jetzt einfach mal einen größeren Push machen könnten,
nachdem die Ukrainer sich zurückgezogen hatten oder die Stellungen,
die du eben erwähnt hast, weiter weg von der Front ausbauen.
Und dachten, sie könnten jetzt schnell mal ein bisschen aufrücken.
Aber das hat halt nicht funktioniert, weil die Ukrainer dann doch die Russen
schon bezahlen lassen, immer für jedes Stückchen Land.
Also da wird nichts umsonst oder kostenlos für die Russen abgegeben.
Und insgesamt auch fand ich es bemerkenswert, dass bisher Russland,
seit sie ihre Offensive begonnen haben,
inklusive Avtivka dann, sondern dass sie immer noch weniger Land besetzt haben,
als die Ukraine in ihrer gescheiterten Offensive oder die als gescheitert wahrgenommene
Offensive im Sommer 2023 war.
Also erfolgreicher als das, was die Russen bisher vorweisen können.
Aber Russen machen halt offenbar auch dieselben Fehler oder sie probieren es
halt immer wieder einfach mit dem Prinzip Brechstange und ja,
das ist halt immer wieder auch teuer.
Und ja also genau
das ist man muss sich da einfach keine Illusionen machen den Russen sind einfach
ihre Leute also im russischen Militär oder der Führung sind einfach die Soldaten
vollkommen egal die werden einfach so lange nach vorne geschickt bis irgendwas hängen bleibt und,
so sind das halt zwar auf dem Papier irgendwelche Landgewinne,
aber militärisch sind sie oft nicht relevant.
Und bis sie wirklich militärisch relevant sind, wenn man überhaupt von Relevanz
sprechen kann, sind dann halt Tausende in den Tod geschickt worden.
Im Fall von Avtivka wahrscheinlich mehrere Zehntausende.
Und das wird halt einfach von hinten durch Mobilisierung wieder durchversorgt Und keiner weiß,
wie lange das halten kann und wie viele Leute zu verheizen die Russen am Ende
wirklich bereit und in der Lage sind.
Ein bisschen bedenklich ist bei Hinterland von Bachmut, wir erinnern uns,
das war ja letztes Jahr so die große Schlacht, wollen die Russen halt jetzt
einen ähnlichen Vorstoß wie bei Avtivka machen,
also darauf alles konzentrieren auf so eine Stadt, die heißt Chassivja,
das ist derzeit eine ziemliche Festung, weil da auch ein Fluss durchgeht.
Also das wird sicherlich nicht einfach werden, aber grundsätzlich ist es halt
derzeit noch für die Ukraine sehr schwierig, die Verteidigungslinien zu halten,
auch wenn es ihnen weitgehend gelingt, weil sie einfach nicht die Munitionsausstattung haben.
Also teilweise haben sie genug Artillerie, Geschütze etc., aber da die Munition
nicht in ausreichenden Mengen vorhanden ist, können sie nicht so gegenhalten
und die Gegenangriffe nicht gleich niederkämpfen, wie es halt angemessen wäre.
Ja, also geht davon aus, dass sie im Moment nur so ein Viertel von dem zur Verfügung haben,
was sie im Sommer eingesetzt haben an Artillerie pro Tag.
So kann man das echt sehen, dass sie ja sagen, die erlaubten Feuerquota sind
ungefähr 25 Prozent derzeit.
Und das ist bisweilen dann eben knapp und kostet dann wahrscheinlich auch mehr
Opfer auf Seiten der Ukraine,
weil sie dann einfach näher ran müssen an den Feind.
Ja. Die GUR, also das ist so der...
Aber was eigentlich die korrekte Bezeichnung für den gebe, der ist ja kein,
ist ein militärischer Geheimdienst, kann man das so sagen, der Ukraine mit ihrem sehr populären Chef,
also der ukrainische Militär-Nachrichtendienst, das ist die korrekte Bezeichnung.
Hur, spricht man das glaube ich aus, mit diesem Budanov als Chef,
die sind ja voll in diesem Krieg, also die sind, klar alles ist im Krieg,
aber das ist so eine relevante Größe.
Also es gibt so das Militär und dann gibt es noch diesen militärischen Geheimdienst,
der immer mit seinen Sonderaktivitäten, aber eben auch mit Veröffentlichungen
immer wieder sich aufmerksam macht und auch dieser Chef, dieser Bulanov ist
halt auf der einen Seite in der
Ukraine ausgesprochen populär als so einer dieser absoluten Top-Helden,
ist ein relativ intelligenter Kerl, der relativ jung ist,
wo die Russen ja auch versucht haben ihn jetzt schon mehrfach umzubringen mit
Giftanschlag auf seine Frau und so weiter.
Also alles mögliche ist da passiert und die warnen davor, dass halt die Russen
im Sommer eine Offensive Richtung der Stadt Petrovsk starten.
Das wäre sozusagen die Verlängerung dieser Avtivka-Angriffslinie.
Muss man mal sehen, was dabei rauskommt. Also so auf dem Boden ist alles nicht
schön, aber da ist es auch für die Russen nicht einfach und diese neue verstärkte
Verteidigungslinie ist schwierig.
Trotzdem, wenn die Ukraine halt nicht die notwendigen Munitionen bekommt,
dann muss man sich auch nicht wundern, wenn es einfach immer wieder Stellen
gibt, wo die Russen dann durchbrechen können und jeder Durchbruch ist schlecht.
Noch viel schlechter als diese Durchbrüche sind die Raketenangriffe auf den Rest der Ukraine.
Die Russen haben extrem ihren Beschuss von Infrastruktur verstärkt und jetzt
zeigt sich langsam die Schwächung der Ukraine, insbesondere im Bereich der Luftverteidigung.
Und das hat nicht nur was mit der Menge an Luftverteidigungssystemen zu tun,
da gab es ja so einiges, aber wenn halt alles angegriffen wird,
dann reicht es halt auch dann nicht.
Aber ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass sie jetzt ein Munitionsproblem haben,
dass sie einfach nicht genug Bewaffnung haben für ihre Patriot-Systeme und vielleicht
auch für die NASA, ich weiß nicht ganz genau.
Darüber sagen sie natürlich jetzt relativ wenig, aber es ist klar,
dass hier ein Mangel herrscht und so ist es dann halt den Russen in den letzten Wochen gelungen,
ganz schlimme Zerstörungen durchzuführen in der Energieinfrastruktur der Ukraine.
Allen voran ist die Stadt Rakiv extrem getroffen worden.
Dort sei jetzt nahezu 100 Prozent der Energieproduktionsinfrastruktur im Eimer.
Teilweise sicherlich auch über ihr Netz noch abgefangen werden,
aber die Stadt ist halt jetzt nachts dunkel und dort ist einfach eine Rationierung.
Ja, also sie haben Rolling Blackouts. So, das ist wohl die aktuelle Situation.
Also es ist jetzt nicht völlig ohne Strom, aber sie müssen halt,
wie es so schön heißt, Load Shedding oder Lastenabwurf betreiben.
Das heißt, stundenweise sind eben Teile ohne Strom und auch die Straßenbeleuchtung
lassen sie abgeschaltet, weil der Strom knapp ist.
Ja, alles was nicht nötig ist, ist halt weg, genau. Und das alles wieder aufzubauen
wird erstmal sehr lange dauern, also ich meine, selbst wenn man jetzt sofort
anfängt, dauert es ein anderthalb Jahr und dann hast du natürlich immer noch das Problem,
dass auch das, was aufgebaut wird, wieder unter Beschuss sein könnte und vor
allem wird es einfach unheimlich viel Geld kosten.
Also wenn man jetzt mal den Preis für Luftverteidigungswaffen im Verhältnis
zu dem, was man später in die Ukraine reinstecken muss, um diese ganze Infrastruktur
wieder aufzubauen vergleicht, das ist einfach keine Rechnung,
die irgendwie Sinn ergibt.
Also das ist einfach ein Skandal, dass die Ukraine an der Stelle so alleine
gelassen wird und da erinnert sich jetzt was dran.
Es gibt jetzt, sogar Deutschland hat jetzt mal angefangen auf die Idee zu kommen,
man könnte ja mal vielleicht sonst noch so in der Welt mal rumfragen,
wer noch so Patchwork-Systeme rumstehen hat und sie vielleicht gerade nicht braucht.
Rauch, da sage ich nur Applaus, habt ihr ja nur zwei Jahre gebraucht für,
aber es ist immer so dieses Elend, es sind dann immer alle total überrascht, ach echt wirklich,
wenn die Russen da 400 Missiles auf euch schicken, dann geht was bei kaputt, das ist ja doof.
Jetzt müssen wir das ja alles wieder heile machen. Dann könnte man ja mal gucken,
ob wir nicht vielleicht ein bisschen Luftverteidigung organisieren können.
Und die Ukraine so, hört ihr uns eigentlich zu?
Ja gut, das ist, ich meine da habe ich aus meiner Zeit in der Politik einfach,
ich weiß nicht ob desillusioniert oder einfach nur die Realitäten zur Kenntnis
genommen, dass in den meisten Fällen die Politik einfach reagiert und nicht agiert.
Also speziell in Deutschland, aber eigentlich generell.
Weil das Problem ist, dass halt solange eine Situation nicht medial bedrohlich genug erscheint,
Und ja, ist es auch schwierig, dann größere Maßnahmen oder Ausgaben zu rechtfertigen.
Und deswegen, ja, plus, dass man nicht
auf alle möglichen Szenarien dann gleichzeitig sich vorbereiten kann.
Man hat schlichtweg einfach nicht die politische Unterstützung.
Das muss halt immer erst mal scheiße werden, bevor man glaubt,
in der Politik die notwendige Rückendeckung zu haben.
Unpopuläre oder vorher unpopuläre Maßnahmen müssen eben erst populär werden,
dadurch, dass sich die Situation verschlechtert oder zuspitzt oder zumindest
die Wahrnehmung der Situation verschlechtert oder zuspitzt.
Und dann kann es halt schnell gehen, aber ja.
Ähm.
Das ist halt auf jeden Fall nicht gut, sagen wir es mal so.
Und das war damals im Zweiten Weltkrieg, war das halt auch nicht anders,
so als die Nazis in Europa auf dem Vormarsch waren.
Da wusste man genau, also ich meine Hitler hatte das ja auch genau aufgeschrieben
und gesagt, was er vorhatte, was er tun würde, das wusste man ja auch.
Aber da musste dann erstmal Pearl Harbor angegriffen werden,
bevor die Amerikaner dann wirklich sich entschieden hatten, mal jetzt was zu tun.
Vorher auch die Munitionsproduktion und alles.
Es waren dann dieselben Debatten, die man halt heute hört.
Trotzdem nicht toll.
Nee, es ist frustrierend. Es ist wirklich, weil es gibt eben auch Leute,
die davon überzeugt sind, dass der richtige Weg ist, jetzt was zu tun.
Und wenn man zu denen gehört oder sich auch vorzubereiten und zwar...
Vielleicht auch mit einer höheren Dringlichkeit vorzubereiten,
als man sie derzeit wahrnimmt bei uns in der Politik.
Klar, aber es gibt dann eben auch die Leute, die dann sagen,
wieso, Russland hat uns doch gar nichts getan.
Was hat Russland denn uns getan, dass es denn jetzt unser Feind sein sollte?
Warum sollten wir uns denn überhaupt so darüber aufregen? Und fand ich halt
auch so eine interessante Frage dann gut, was hat Russland uns eigentlich getan?
Ich meine, nur um so ein paar Dinge zu erwähnen, weil man vergisst das ja dann leicht so.
Aber ich meine, Russland hat versucht, bei uns Leute zum Erfrieren zu bringen.
Russland hat uns das Gas abgedreht.
Und zwar bevor die Pipelines gesprengt wurden. Da braucht man die Debatte gar nicht.
Sondern Russland hat Putin-Regierung sich entschieden,
50 Jahre erfolgreiche deutsch-russische Außenpolitik und Freundschaft einfach
in den Orkus zu kippen, indem sie mit dem Gashahn gespielt haben.
Und mit dem erklärten Ziel, bei uns maximalen Schaden anzurichten.
Sie mischen sich überall in Wahlen ein, sie unterstützen Extremisten und Terrorgruppen
in Europa auf jeden Fall.
In Deutschland würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn das der Fall wäre,
aber es gibt in vielen anderen Nachbarländern ganz klar nachgewiesene Sabotagetätigkeiten.
Tschechien zum Beispiel, wo Russland dann schon 2014, 2015...
Die Sprengstoffanschläge auf Munitionsfabriken und Munitionsdepots durchgeführt
hat mit Hilfe des Geheimdienstes.
Und wenn man bedenkt, das ist Schengen-Raum.
Plus dann das Ding, dass sie halt Flüchtlinge an die Grenzen karren und versuchen,
Flüchtlinge zu weaponisen an eben auch verschiedenen Schengen-Außengrenzen.
Sie bringen Leute um, so in Sprechweite des Bundestages?
Genau, hier gleich um die Ecke im Tiergarten und so schicken Mörder bei uns ins Land.
Ach ja, und sind halt mit auch organisierten Verbrechen bei uns dort verbandelt.
Siehe hier der Wirecard-Skandal, wo sie jetzt einen der Hauptverantwortlichen,
der war auf ihrer Payroll und hält sich jetzt auch in Russland auf und hat Informationen,
Geheiminformationen weitergegeben und hat es eben russischem organisierten Verbrechen
auch ermöglicht, Banktransaktionen und Zahlungen.
Und wer weiß, wie viele Milliarden unauffällig zu verschieben und Gelder zu bewegen und so.
Ja, also das ist, fragt, okay, was hat Russland uns getan?
Ja und man muss auch sehen, man muss sich nur russisches Fernsehen anschauen,
wo einfach Tag ein Tag aus auf diesen Propagandakanälen und Sendungen einfach
die Zerstörung Berlins und irgendwie Atombeschuss auf London und überhaupt generell
der Niedergang der Westkultur beschworen wird.
Und einfach täglich irgendwelche Gewaltfantasien ausgelebt werden.
Ich meine, das ist nicht das, was der Kreml tut.
Aber das ist das, was der Kreml diesen Leuten sagen lässt.
Es wird also die ganze Zeit eine antiwestliche Stimmung befördert und die schreckt
halt auch nicht davor zurück,
hier sozusagen permanent den Atomtod in Europa komplett für einen ganz gangbaren Weg zu halten.
Das ist Gerede, das werden sie auch nicht tun, so doof ist noch nicht mal Russland,
weil sie wissen, dann ist es halt richtig vorbei,
aber nichtsdestotrotz derzeit ist einfach von diesem Land nichts Positives zu
erwarten und selbst wenn einem das alles noch egal ist.
Dieser Krieg macht bei uns auch alles teurer.
Dieser Krieg sorgt dafür, dass unsere Wirtschaft geschwächt wird.
Dieser Krieg sorgt dafür, dass es eine Sicherheitsinstabilität gibt.
Dieser Krieg sorgt dafür, dass wir jetzt wenig Möglichkeiten haben,
als den Militärhaushalt europaweit enorm hochzuschrauben, aufzurüsten,
sehr viel Geld in solche Dinge investieren müssen,
die sehr viel besser in Klimaschutz und soziale Aktivitäten investiert wäre.
Man kann Deutschland wirklich auch nicht vorwerfen, Russland in eine Rüstungsspirale
getrieben zu haben, sondern im Gegenteil.
Ich meine, der Punkt ist, dass die meisten westlichen Länder eigentlich lieber
eher abrüsten würden. Oder tendenziell, wir ja eine riesige Abrüstungsphase
gesehen haben im Westen.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass der Westen sich jetzt darauf vorbereitet hat,
um jetzt in Russland einzumarschieren.
Oder die Russen, die Russen waren eigentlich abgehakt. Die hatte man gar nicht
mehr auf dem Schirm überhaupt so. Richtig.
Und ja, ja.
Deswegen, was Russland da jetzt treibt, das ist nicht provoziert.
Und wie gesagt,
selbst ganz unabhängig von, ich meine, was alles Russland, wo Russland hin will
oder hin kann oder was sie halt gerne uns antun würden oder nicht antun würden.
Ich finde das, was sie hier getrieben haben, reicht eigentlich schon vollkommen aus.
Gut, lass uns den Punkt dann vielleicht auch später nochmal anders aufgreifen.
Vielleicht noch einen Nachtrag zu dieser Geschichte der Angriffen auf Raketenenergieinfrastruktur.
Also sie haben ja auch einen Angriff auf den Nipro-Damm bei Saporizia durchgeführt
mit Missiles und zwar mit ihren richtig dicken, fetten, großen Raketen.
Ob es ihr Ziel war, den Damm komplett zu zerstören, kann man nicht sagen.
Ich würde sagen, es ist ihnen auf jeden Fall nicht gelungen,
aber es ist ihnen gelungen die Kraftwerkinfrastruktur dieses Damms weitgehend
zu zerstören oder zumindest zu stören.
Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht in welchem Zustand der ist, da ist nicht alles im
Eimer, aber das ist auch alles nicht ohne weiteres zu reparieren.
Also auch da ging es an die Energieinfrastruktur und ich meine sie haben schon
einen Damm gesprengt und wenn es ihnen gelingen würde mit solchen Angriffen,
was hier jetzt nicht gelungen ist, aber sie nehmen es ja zumindest billigend in Kauf,
also angenommen dieser Damm wäre jetzt gebrochen, so wie der andere Damm gebrochen ist.
Dann hätte das eine vollständige Überflutung der Stadt Zaporizia zur Folge gehabt
mit irgendwie Millionen Menschen.
Also die Zahl der absolut verwerflichen Taten, die ist schon so lang,
aber die wird jetzt auch insbesondere durch diese Angriffe, die jetzt eben in
zunehmendem Maße nicht verhindert werden können, weil es eben keine ausreichenden
Schutzmaßnahmen gibt, weil wir die nicht bereitstellen.
Wenn die halt so weitergehen. Aber schauen wir mal, was jetzt die Ukraine noch so leisten kann.
Wir haben jetzt vor allem von den Angriffen der Russen gesprochen.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die Ukraine da nur jetzt mit dem Arsch auf ihren
Händen sitzt, sondern es geschehen Dinge.
Und es geschehen auch merkwürdige Dinge, weil es gab ziemlich bald nachdem unsere Sendung war,
gab es Angriffe und zwar das zweite Mal jetzt in diesem Krieg von so russischen
Einheiten, die aber auf der Seite der Ukraine kämpfen.
Also es sind Russen, zumindest wird das so dargestellt, aber es ist so.
Drei, vier verschiedene Gruppen mit unterschiedlichen Freiheit für Russland,
und die haben wiederum in der Nordgrenze der Ukraine,
also in der russischen Region Belgorod, an vier Stellen grenzüberschritten und
die Grenzdörfer angegriffen.
Da gab es natürlich den entsprechenden Widerstand der Russen,
aber da hatten die auf jeden Fall erstmal wieder ganz schön mit zu tun.
Das hielt so eine Woche ungefähr, ist ein bisschen unklar wann die sich dann
wieder zurückgezogen haben.
Also so eine ähnliche Geschichte, wie es das schon im letzten Jahr gab und so
ein bisschen merkwürdig, was
da eigentlich passiert und was sozusagen der Sinn der ganzen Sache ist,
weil du kannst jetzt nicht so mit drei Jeeps und zwei Tankern kannst du nicht
irgendwie in Russland einfallen und davon ausgehen, dass du jetzt irgendwie
den Kreml niederringst.
Aber trotzdem müssen natürlich die Russen immer darauf bedacht sein,
dass sie dort eben ihre eigenen Gebiete auch noch schützen und das war glaube
ich so ein bisschen der Sinn der ganzen Sache, dass einfach auch die Russen
von ihrer Intelligence her beschäftigt sind und sich nicht auf ihre eigenen
Offensiven kümmern können.
Ja, es war einfach mehr ein klassischer Raid oder Überfall,
wo man mit der begrenzten Zahl von Truppen irgendwo einfällt,
für Unruhe und Chaos und Zerstörung und Schrecken sorgt, Aber nicht damit rechnet,
irgendwie jetzt Land zu erobern und zu befestigen und zu halten,
sondern will eben eine Reaktion dann provozieren und zieht sich dann anschließend
wieder zurück, weil man auch eben ja gar nicht die Logistik hat,
um dann jetzt Truppen auf dem Vormarsch zu versorgen, sondern man nimmt dann
halt für eine Woche was zu essen mit. So.
Aber, ähm,
Und welche Gruppen die es mit welcher Intention abgeschickt haben und was die
eigentlichen Ziele waren, wird aus den Berichten nicht so richtig klar.
Aber auch da zeigt sich, dass Russland halt einfach die Sicherheit in ihren
eigenen Städten gar nicht mehr aufrechterhalten kann. Also zumindest nicht in
Belgorod und auch in Rostov-on-Don sieht es nicht so gut aus dafür.
Ja und das gehört irgendwie in dieses ganze Kapitel Vorstoß am Norden.
Auf der anderen Seite ist die Ukraine ja eher dabei, diese Grenze so hermetisch
abzuregeln, wie es nur irgendwie geht.
Und ich glaube so Vorstöße aus dem Norden Richtung Kiew und Sumi und so weiter,
also Einmarsch ins ukrainische Land, das glaube ich kann man jetzt erstmal vergessen,
da haben die Russen keine Möglichkeit.
Man macht dann mit solchen Drohnenangriffen macht man zum Beispiel auch die Luftabwehr nervös,
die dann wiederum dazu tendiert eventuell auf alles zu schießen,
was sich auch hinter der Front bewegt.
Deswegen willst du quasi auch dort diesen Druck aufrecht erhalten,
um es auch einfach schwieriger zu machen der anderen Seite und das hat auch gewisse Erfolge.
Plus, dass es so scheint, dass die Russen bei ihren Gleitbomben-Kits das Problem,
was wir glaube ich vor einem Jahr schon mal erwähnt haben, immer noch nicht
voll in den Griff gekriegt haben.
Und zwar ist das Problem, diese Gleitbomben-Kits haben halt so Flügel,
die so scherenmäßig mit Federn versehen sind,
damit sie halt während des Fluges eben eingeklappt sind und dann nach dem Abwurf
klappen halt diese Flügel aus und die Bombe kann mit dem Gleitkit dann GPS und,
oder trickheitsgesteuert so je nach Höhe 50 bis 70 Kilometer fliegen.
Jetzt scheint es so zu sein, dass einige dieser russischen Gleitkits einfach
die Flügel nicht ausklappen.
Und es scheint es weitere dann auch so zu sein, dass das Ausklappen dieser Flügel
nicht unbedingt dazu führt, dass die Bombe unscharf ist.
Sprich, wenn die halt dann und dann ist es so,
dass sie gerne auch offensichtlich diese Abwürfe in der Gegend um Belgorod machen
und deswegen passiert es eben immer noch,
dass gelegentlich auf und um Belgorod halt russische Bomben einschlagen,
weil die Gleitkits sich gelegentlich nicht öffnen.
Und teilweise wird aber auch gemunkelt,
dass die Piloten irgendwie selber machen oder irgendwelche Fehler passieren
dann oder die nicht näher ran wollen und Angst haben und dann lieber den Kram
einfach irgendwie abwerfen und loswerden wollen.
Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall bestätigte aktuelle Berichte über russische Bomben,
die in und um Belgorod eingeschlagen sind.
Genau.
So, aber noch sehr viel wichtiger und sehr viel erfolgreicher sind die Angriffe
der Ukraine mit ihrem Drohnenprogramm und wir hatten ja auch schon darüber gesprochen,
dass die Drohnenproduktion in der Ukraine ein absoluter Fokus ist und mit Drohnen
meinen wir eigentlich alles an Drohnen.
Das heißt nicht nur jetzt diese Quadrokopter, die man jetzt oft in diesen Videos sieht,
wenn man sich ein bisschen mit dem Frontgeschehen beschäftigt,
die halt jetzt direkt in Panzer und sonstige Fahrzeuge fliegen und explodieren
oder Bomben oder Granaten abwerfen und dann Fahrzeuge zum Explodieren bringen,
sondern Drohnen ist mittlerweile weit gefasst.
Wir haben ja schon sehr viel über diese Seedrohnen gesprochen.
Es gibt teilweise eben jetzt auch Drohnen für die Versorgung der Frontline,
also so Fahrzeuge, die mehr oder weniger autonom, teilweise noch ferngesteuert
mit Quadro-Koppern beobachtet,
was weiß ich, Munition in den Schützengraben nach vorne fahren, solche Geschichten.
Aber ganz wichtig sind natürlich die großen Luftdrohnen und damit macht die
Ukraine den Russen gerade das Leben richtig schwer,
denn sie bauen halt einerseits große Drohnen, die sehr viel Sprengkraft mit
sich führen, aber vor allem die auch eine unglaubliche Reichweite haben.
Das ging jetzt gerade in den letzten Wochen enorm los,
dass die Ukraine ganz gezielt Gas- und Ölproduktionsstätten,
also Raffinerien der Russen, angreifen.
Eigentlich nahezu alle Raffinerien, die so High-Quality-Produkte erzeugen.
Also sowas wie PKW-Benzin.
Also alles das, was auch die Russen exportieren können.
Jetzt nicht so schlechter Diesel, den sie so in den Panzer reinschmeißt oder
so. Das haben sie irgendwie überall.
Aber alles, was so ein bisschen High-Quality erzeugt, davon haben sie irgendwie
so 10, 15 Standorte. Aber die sind halt alle im Wesentlichen in Russland.
Mit anderen Worten, die sind auch alle verhältnismäßig nah an der Ukraine dran.
Und von den Standorten sind gut 80 Prozent,
auch nur 70 Prozent, aber auf jeden Fall weitaus mehr als die Hälfte in den
letzten Wochen von großen Flugdrohnen getroffen worden.
Und das bedeutet, dass die Ukraine
mittlerweile über Drohnentechnologie verfügt und auch in der Lage ist,
die über sowohl besetztes ukrainisches Gebiet als eben auch über normales russisches
Staatsgebiet fliegen zu lassen, über 1000 Kilometer weit.
Und mittlerweile gibt es auch Hinweise bzw.
Auch Ankündigungen schon, dass sie auch bei diesen 1000 Kilometern nicht Halt
machen, sondern dass sie teilweise Drohnen haben, die bis zu 3300 Kilometer weit kommen.
Nochmal zu den Angriffen auf die Öl- und Gasproduktion, nochmal zur Reichweite
gleich nochmal einen anderen Gedanken, aber warum greifen sie diese Städten an?
Könnte man ja denken, wenn das nicht der Treibstoff für die Panzer ist,
was soll's? Also, dass den Russen mal der Diesel ausgeht, das steht nicht zu befürchten.
Dafür haben die einfach zu viel Produktion. Aber mit diesen Öl- und Gasproduktionsstätten
machen sie ihre Exporte.
In anderen Worten, das sind die Haupteinnahmequellen Russlands.
Und in den letzten Wochen sind diese Einnahmen nach Schätzung um 12-15% schon zurückgegangen.
Das heißt Russland verdient weniger Geld und das ist halt die,
großem Abstand die Haupteinnahmequelle dieses Staates, weil sie diese ganzen
Produktionsstätten schließen mussten.
Und zwar nicht nur welche, die jetzt irgendwie 100-200 Kilometer von der ukrainischen
Grenze entfernt sind, sondern nahezu alle bis hin zu St.
Petersburg. Und auch tief in russisches Gebiet rein, eben über 1200 Kilometer
weit wurden halt diese Anlagen angegriffen.
Das sind teilweise riesige Anlagen, wo man sich dann auch nur denkt,
naja okay, was macht das jetzt schon aus, wenn da irgendwo eine Drohne explodiert.
Aber sie haben wohl es geschafft, den Zielanflug so genau zu machen,
dass sie eben diese Anlagen an ganz spezifischen Punkten treffen.
Und zwar nämlich genau dort, wo das teure, wo sozusagen diese Flaschenhalse in der Produktion sind.
Also du setzt ein System außer Betrieb und damit setzt du im Prinzip die gesamte Fabrik außer Betrieb.
Und es sind dann auch noch die am teuersten und am schwierigsten zu ersetzenden
Komponenten, weil hier die Russen eben oft auf Westtechnologie angewiesen sind.
Und das scheint eine sehr erfolgreiche Strategie zu sein.
Jetzt gab es zuletzt diese Angriffe sogar auch auf diese Shahed-Fabrik,
die auch irgendwie 1500 Kilometer weit weg ist von der Ukraine.
Also da, wo diese Shahed-Drohnen gebaut werden, die ja eigentlich von den Iranern entwickelt wurden.
Da gab es ein Video zu sehen, wie so eine Drohne da reingeflogen ist.
Aber dazu überhaupt noch Drohne zu sagen, ist irgendwie auch noch absurd.
Du hast das Video wahrscheinlich gesehen.
Es sieht aus wie ein Leichtflugzeug eher. Also man denkt, da könnte auch ein
Pilot drin sitzen und das da reingesteuert haben.
So nur von der, wie das von außen, von Weitem aussah.
Genau, also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob es das war,
aber es gibt ein extrem populäres und sehr erfolgreiches Zweisitzflugzeug, Leichtflugzeug,
die A22 Foxbat von Aeroprakt und die ist weltweit irgendwie im Einsatz.
Und das war so eine der Sachen, die ich gehört habe, dass sie also auf Basis
dieses Modells Drohnen gebaut haben, aber das ist mit Sicherheit auch nicht die einzige Variante.
Also es scheinen eine ganze Vielzahl von unterschiedlichsten,
also alles was fliegen kann wird quasi in Drohne umgebaut, so kann man es glaube ich mal sagen.
Und es ist erstaunlich, dass sie mit diesen Maschinen, die ja noch nicht mal
besonders hoch und auch nicht besonders schnell fliegen können,
in der Lage sind, tausende Kilometer über russischem Staatsgebiet zu überfliegen,
ohne irgendwie abgefangen zu werden und dann eben auch noch genau ihr Ziel zu treffen.
Also ob sie jetzt immer ihr Ziel genau treffen,
weiß ich nicht, aber viele dieser Produktionsanlagen sind jetzt außer Betrieb genommen worden,
wegen unangekündigter Vorfälle und das tut den Russen natürlich mittelfristig schon sehr weh.
Es wird auch weiterhin gemunkelt, dass sie auch hier jetzt schon eine Zielführung
und eine Flugnavigation haben, die eben zumindest teilweise.
Zumindest im Zielanflug so auf AI-Basis läuft.
Also ich habe das mal so Low-Coast-Taurus genannt, darüber hatten wir uns ja
in der letzten Sendung ausführlich unterhalten,
wie die Taurus eben einfach durch das Auswerten von Höhenprofil ihren ganzen
Flugweg finden kann und am Ende auch das eigentliche Zielmeter genau ansteuern kann.
Und eine ähnliche Technik scheinen die Ukrainer auch hier entwickelt zu haben.
Mit anderen Worten, wenn die so auf diese Anlagen zufliegen,
dann können sie, und das weiß ich natürlich jetzt nicht, wie es funktioniert,
ob sie da mit LIDAR arbeiten, ob sie da mit optischen Kameras arbeiten oder
was auch immer die Basis ist.
Auf jeden Fall, sie können sich dann auf den letzten Metern in diesem Terrain
genau orientieren und dann eben auch wirklich zielgerichtet genau dahin fliegen
und dort eine Sprengung auslösen, wo sie es gerne haben wollen.
Und das führt eben jetzt dazu.
Ja, und wenn du überlegst, in meinen letzten Jahrzehnten hat ja auch die Avionik
große Fortschritte gemacht.
Du hast ja auch in Leichtflugzeugen jetzt so Glas-Displays und Motoren mit automatischem
Engine-Management und Autopilot mit Kopplung an Navigationssysteme.
Das wiegt alles nichts mehr und da fehlt dann nicht wirklich viel,
wenn du so eine moderne Avionicsuite hast,
da noch einen Rechner mit ein paar Kameras dran anzuschließen.
Die Automatisierung von dem Flugzeug selber ist schon da, es weiß,
wo es ist, wie hoch es fliegt und so und hat einen Autopiloten,
der es selber steuern kann.
Den kann man noch ein bisschen mehr Autorität geben, dass der halt extremere
Manöver fliegen kann. Ja, und...
Dann ist man vielleicht bei, in der Größenordnung bei ein paar hunderttausend für eine Drohne,
die dann eine Reichweite von tausend bis zweitausend Kilometern haben kann und
wahrscheinlich eine Nutzlast,
sagen wir mal typischerweise 200 Kilo, sowas in der Gegend, könnten die da an
Sprengstoff mit reinpacken in so ein kleines Flugzeug.
Es ist natürlich schon krass, so dieses Verschmelzen von Ziviltechnologie und
militärischer Technologie, das ist eigentlich nicht das, was man möchte.
So, weil...
Äußern etc. Und dafür hat die Ukraine halt keine Zeit.
Also nach diesem Krieg wird die Militärproduktion in der Ukraine wahrscheinlich,
in manchen Bereichen ausgesprochen modern geworden sein.
Also das kann man schon sicher sagen.
Gut, dem gesamten Konflikt, der militärische Konflikt hat aber auch Auswirkungen auf uns, auf Europa.
Nicht nur die indirekten, die wir schon angesprochen haben, sondern auch so ganz konkret.
Es gab Mitte März, war Cameron, der mittlerweile Außenminister von UK,
war in der Ukraine und auf dem Rückflug von Polen aus gab es wohl Probleme mit dem GPS-Signal.
Und stellt sich raus, dass das wohl mit russischem GPS-Jemming zu tun hat.
Es gibt bei Flightradar so eine GPS-Jemming-Map, wo auch immer angezeigt wird,
in welchen Regionen dieser Welt in irgendeiner Form mit Störsendern gearbeitet wird.
Also GPS-Jemming bedeutet ja im Kern, dass man die Frequenzen,
die die GPS-Satelliten zur Erde schicken und damit quasi ihre Zeit übertragen,
aus der man dann die Position berechnen kann,
dass die halt gestört werden,
indem man auf derselben Frequenz mit stärkerem Signal sendet.
Und das bezeichnet man halt als Jamming und,
ja, wenn man dann auf diese Karten schaut, dann sieht man das halt GPS-Jamming
ist so in so Bereichen wie Syrien auch im Osten der Türkei, aber natürlich in
der Ukraine sehr verbreitet,
aber eben auch im Königsberg herum in anderen Worten die Russen stören auch
GPS-Signale und das hat dann eben auch noch Auswirkungen auf die zivile Luftfahrt,
Also das ist auf jeden Fall ganz interessant.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man sich da am besten vor schützen kann.
Was auf jeden Fall helfen könnte, ist, dass man dann auch GLONASS verwendet.
Das ist nämlich das Navigationssystem der Russen.
Aber das ist noch störanfälliger. Also er hat mir sagen lassen,
das ist dann nicht wirklich eine Alternative und die billigen Systeme nutzen ja sowieso alles.
Aber GLONASS pfeift halt ohnehin auf dem letzten Loch, was die Satellitenkonstellationen angeht.
Die sind teilweise schon länger oben, als sie eigentlich sollten.
Und die haben Mühe, die Russen haben Mühe, die Konstellationen am Laufen zu halten.
Und das schon länger, schon seit zehn Jahren ungefähr, kann man sagen.
Also haben da ein bisschen aufgeholt. Also aber es ist immer noch,
sie liegen einfach zeitlich weiter zurück und deswegen,
also GLONASS ist da auch nicht wirklich eine Alternative und im Grunde genommen, ja,
diese Frequenzen sind halt durch internationale Abkommen so,
die ITU, die International Telecommunication Union,
regelt, glaube ich, dort generell so Frequenzvergaben.
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt hingehst und als Staat ein Militär dann irgendeinen
Jammer betreibt, der dann ins Nachbarland ausstrahlt, ja,
dann ist das schon halt ein Verstoß einfach gegen ein internationales Abkommen.
Und das Ding ist, ich...
Ich habe jetzt vor einer Woche oder so mit einer OSZE-Diplomatin gesprochen.
Die OSZE ist ja die Organisation für Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa.
Also ex, ich sag mal, was damals früher der Helsinki-Prozess war und so.
Und 50 Länder sind dort Mitglieder. Und unter anderem aber auch natürlich Russland und Weißrussland.
Und ich habe dann gefragt, ja, wie läuft denn, also was ist jetzt so die Rolle
der OSZE eigentlich seit dem Ukraine-Krieg?
Und dann hieß es, naja, im Wesentlichen, dass 48 Länder alle auf Russland einprügeln,
diplomatisch. So, außer Weißrussland.
Also denen halt täglich zu zeigen, wie isoliert sie unter 50 europäischen Ländern
eigentlich dastehen für ihre Akte und Aktionen.
Und dieses GPS-Jamming ist jetzt dann ein weiteres Ding,
also es reicht halt sogar an manchen Tagen, ging es sogar bis Mecklenburg-Vorpommern rein,
das heißt, wenn jemand an manchen Tagen vielleicht in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
so sein Autonavigationsgerät anfängt rumzuspinnen und die Position hin und her
hüpft und es lange dauert und immer wieder das GPS versagt,
kann sich dann auch bei den Russen dafür bedanken, unter Umständen,
dass sie dort von Kaliningrad aus bis nach Deutschland rein,
Funkwellen jammern in Verstoß gegen internationale Abkommen.
Ja, es gibt ähnliche Probleme auch derzeit in Israel. Also auch da ist das Jamming
sozusagen Gang und Gäbe.
Ja, also soviel auch nochmal zum Thema. Betrifft uns das eigentlich?
Ja, kann man schon sagen. Also betrifft uns dann doch ganz nachhaltig.
So, dann gab es ja noch eine Wahl, angeblich.
Wo ganz überraschend Putin wiedergewählt wurde,
weil er so ein unglaublich toller, beliebter Kerl ist und deswegen ja auch 87,5.
Prozent der Stimmen bekommen hat. Gut, das ist halt sozusagen die offiziell kommunizierte Zahl.
Jeder weiß, dass das nicht wirklich den Stimmen entspricht.
Es gibt schöne viele Videos, wo so Mitarbeiterinnen dabei gefilmt werden,
wie sie in Wahllokalen bei irgendwelchen Pausen oder nachts,
ich weiß nicht ganz genau, so mit größeren Zettelmengen ankommen und die dann
noch in die Wahlurnen reinstopfen und so.
Aber ich glaube, auch das wäre nicht unbedingt erforderlich gewesen.
Es gab ja nicht wirklich unabhängige Gegenkandidaten.
Gab es nicht. Und die paar, die es hätten vielleicht sein können,
sind ja alle verboten worden.
So funktioniert das. Also insofern, man muss halt das Ganze als politisches Signal sehen.
Also diese 87 Prozent, die da kommuniziert wurden,
sind sozusagen die Botschaft, ja also ihr braucht gar nicht drüber nachzudenken,
irgendwas gegen Putin zu unternehmen.
Ja der ist jetzt hier einfach Diktator auf Lebenszeit, nicht dass ihr das eh
schon wusstet, aber wir haben es jetzt halt einfach mal auf elf gedreht.
Und das ist sozusagen jetzt die Situation.
Ja und dann hat es auch nicht so lange gedauert, wie schon erwartet wurde,
dass dann eben so erste Mobilisierungsankündigungen stattgefunden haben,
weil jetzt war die Wahl halt durch,
also diese Demonstration der Stärke, würde ich es mal nennen und ja dann kam,
Kann man wieder dazu beitragen, die Laune der Leute zu verschlechtern,
weil was soll da noch groß passieren?
Und dann gab es halt erstmal so die Meldung, dass sie irgendwie,
das war schon ein bisschen älter glaube ich, dass sie so generell nochmal ihr
Militär nochmal ein paar Brigaden ausbauen wollen oder Subarmeen.
Und dann schlich jetzt auch vor kurzem noch so die Zahl von 300.000 Leuten,
die sie jetzt nachrekrutieren wollen, wobei das halt die normalen Rekruten wahrscheinlich
sind, die jetzt ohnehin zum Anfang des Jahres anstehen, verpflichtet zu werden.
Also ist nicht so ganz klar, aber es ist eine Vergrößerung des Militärs angekündigt
werden, inwiefern Russland überhaupt in der Lage ist, sein Militär zu vergrößern.
Also, weil das ist schon groß angelegt, nur du musst die Leute ja auch irgendwie
ausrüsten, du musst die Leute auch ausbilden, du hast halt nichts anderes vor,
als sie direkt an die Grenze zu schicken, um sie dort sterben zu lassen.
Ist ein bisschen unklar. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, was ich davon halten
soll, aber es ist nicht ganz auszuschließen, dass sie halt alles tun,
Und es gibt auch genug Gerüchte, die sagen, es gelingt ihnen ohnehin einfach
über ihre Rekrutierungsprogramme jeden Monat irgendwie 30.000 wieder neue dem
Gemetzel hinzuzufügen.
Ja, aber das brauchen sie ja auch, weil das ist ja auch ungefähr die Größenordnung,
die sie mindestens verlieren.
Entweder durch Tod, Krankheit, Unfälle, altersbedingtes Ausscheiden,
zu lange an der Front, wie auch immer.
Immer so, es ist ja nicht wie so ein Sparschwein, wo du reinsteckst und dann
bleiben die alle drin, die Leute in der Armee.
Und insofern muss, und das betrifft natürlich auch die Ukraine,
muss halt regelmäßig weiter und neu rekrutiert werden auf beiden Seiten.
Und Russland braucht eben allein 30.000 bis 50.000 im Monat,
um Verluste und Abgänge auszugleichen.
Was halt diese ganzen Zahlenspiele irgendwie immer schwierig macht. Das heißt...
Die Vergrößerung des Militärs um 240.000 bis 768.000 haben wir schon mehrfach jetzt gehört.
Aber wie du schon richtig sagst, ist die Frage, was kommt tatsächlich dazu.
Aber unterm Strich sieht es zumindest so aus, dass das russische Militär zumindest,
was die Truppenanzahl angeht, nicht kleiner wird, sondern tendenziell größer wird.
So das, würde ich sagen, ist der Eindruck, der bei mir aus all den Berichten
und Zahlen hängen geblieben ist.
Aber es sieht für mich nicht so aus, als wenn sie in kürzester Zeit ihre Truppen
verdoppeln könnten oder sowas in der Art.
Sondern irgendwo liegt die Wahrheit in der Mitte. Aber es ist so schon besorgniserregend
trotzdem und eigentlich müsste man darauf reagieren.
Also Russland rüstet auf, aber noch nicht in dem Tempo, wie es könnte,
wenn es jetzt eine Totalmobilmachung durchführen und komplett auf Kriegswirtschaft umstellen würde.
Also da, an dem Punkt ist Russland noch nicht.
Auf Kriegswirtschaft haben sie schon umgestellt.
Ja, aber nicht komplett so. Also es ist nicht so, dass sie jetzt,
ja, alles andere, die haben jetzt nicht angefangen, Nahrungsmittel zu rationieren
oder andere Dinge des täglichen Bedarfs.
Es ist halt alles teurer geworden. und gut belarus darf jetzt kein sprit mehr
exportieren doch nach russland außer nach russland genau.
Stichwort Mobilisierung, das steht natürlich jetzt auch der Ukraine bevor.
Es gab in den letzten Monaten eine breitere Diskussion in der Ukraine,
wie denn mit der Mobilisierung generell zu verfahren sei, beziehungsweise mit
der Rekrutierung generell zu verfahren sei.
Und es ist ja tatsächlich so und damit ist Ukraine auch ein absolutes Unikum,
die ukrainischen Soldaten, die für den Krieg einberufen werden,
wurden bislang erst ab dem Alter von 27 Jahren einberufen.
Und das wirkt natürlich ein bisschen merkwürdig, weil man sich denkt so,
warte mal, seid ihr nicht gerade im Krieg und werft ihr nicht irgendwie alles
nach vorne, aber so ist die Gesetzeslage.
Und der Grund dafür, was sozusagen damit bezweckt werden soll,
dass man eben die ganz Jungen nicht in den Krieg holt, ist, um ihnen sozusagen
auch noch die Gelegenheit zu geben,
ja zynisch betrachtet auch noch eine Familie zu gründen, aber sagen wir mal
überhaupt einfach so ihr Leben auch einfach zu leben.
Ich meine, wenn du 16, 17 bist, dann ist dein größtes Ziel ja nicht,
jetzt will ich irgendwie gegen die Russen in den Krieg ziehen,
sondern du bist ja gerade dabei, überhaupt erstmal dich selber zu entdecken
und dein Leben so richtig zu starten.
Und das ist etwas, was in der Ukraine eben auch gesetzlich eben auch im Falle
dieses Krieges so gilt, dass eben die ganz jungen Leute nicht einfach an der Front verheizt werden.
Nichtsdestotrotz hat natürlich auch die Ukraine das Problem,
dass sie irgendwelche Leute finden muss, die in den Krieg ziehen, weil sonst….
Die machen die Russen den Krieg alleine und das ist nicht so das,
was jetzt gerade geboten ist.
Deswegen gab es eine, wie ich so mitbekommen habe,
recht emotional geführte Debatte in der Ukraine und jetzt ist beschlossen worden,
dieses Eintrittsalter auf 25 abzusenken.
Das heißt jetzt gibt es kurzzeitig eine Welle, weil eben zwei Jahrgänge zusätzlich
mit aufgenommen werden können,
die vorher sozusagen noch außerhalb des Einzugsbereichs waren.
Und im selben Zuge wurden auch,
im Krieg ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz so sicher, was deren Status war,
aber es sind halt viele eben auch einfach aus diesem Modus gar nicht rausgekommen
und kämpfen halt seit zwei Jahren in diesem Krieg, was auch nicht so geil ist und die sind halt jetzt,
die ersten sind jetzt eben raus rotiert worden.
Dem wurde halt einfach gesagt, so ja vielen Dank, du hast jetzt hier irgendwie
zwei Jahre für uns gekämpft, super war, jetzt mal Schluss.
Und ja, das ist sozusagen gerade die Methode, mit der die Ukraine dort vorgeht,
die sich halt von der russischen Methode doch fundamental unterscheidet.
Ja. Und auch, ich meine, als ich das gehört hatte, wurde ich an einen Popsong
erinnert, aus den, ich glaube, 80ern, der irgendwie, der Refrain war in der 19.
So das Durchschnittsalter der amerikanischen Rekruten im Vietnamkrieg.
Deswegen fand ich das besonders bemerkenswert.
Also ich hörte, dass die Ukraine erst ab 1927 bisher eingezogen hat.
Das ist in der Tat sehr ungewöhnlich und unerhört eigentlich.
Weil das macht es auch nicht unbedingt einfacher, dann Leute einzuziehen,
weil so 19-Jährige sind halt noch formbarer, mit denen kannst du halt anders
umspringen als mit jemandem, der halt schon eine Ausbildung hinter sich hat,
der vielleicht schon Familienvater ist und schon eigentlich erwachsen ist.
Das heißt, du hast dann eben auch eher so eine Erwachsenenarmee und keine jugendlichen
Armee, was auch interessante Implikationen haben könnte.
Das Lied 19 von Paul Hardcastle besingt dann eben auch den Umstand,
dass im Zweiten Weltkrieg das Durchschnittsalter der Kampfsoldaten bei 26 lag.
Und in Vietnam war es dann halt 19,
Gut, jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie kann man der Ukraine helfen
und da ist viel passiert in den letzten Wochen.
Ich glaube wir hatten diese von den Tschechen initiierte Geschichte,
sich auf die Suche nach Artillerie, Munition zu begeben, haben wir glaube ich schon erwähnt.
Und dass da eben Geld eingesammelt wurde, das Geld ist wohl soweit ich das sehe
weitgehend zusammen und angeblich soll es jetzt auch schon im April erste Lieferungen geben.
In dem Zuge wurde auch die Menge von Shells, die man dort angeblich aufgetan
hat und die dann auch binnen einer überschaubaren Zeit geliefert werden können,
von 800.000 auf eine Million hoch korrigiert.
Und das scheint jetzt sozusagen unterwegs zu sein.
Und jetzt gab es auch noch eine Meldung
von Estland, dass sie auch nochmal Artillerie-Shells besorgen können.
Ja, wird man sehen, was daraus wird, aber ja.
Also von der Menge her, also über zwei Milliarden US-Dollar Beschaffungsmenge,
bei den Tschechen waren es anderthalb, wenn ich das richtig sehe,
also eine Million Shell, also wäre das sozusagen nochmal irgendwie mehr als
eine Million, wenn es jetzt nur um Artillery Shells geht.
Also das war ja, sind ja viele Waffentypen sind ja hier gefragt.
Der Mangel an Luftverteidigungsraketen, den haben wir schon angesprochen,
aber es geht natürlich auch generell Munition auch für ganz Maschinengewehre etc.
Aber das ist ja im Vergleich alles Pipifax. Problematisch war halt nur Artillery-Shells,
also das, was du in Hobbitsen und ähnliche Systeme einsetzen kannst,
diese 155 Millimeter-Shells für NATO-Material und 152 für russische Geräte,
die die Ukraine ja auch noch hat.
Ja, also eine Million würde ungefähr größenordnungsmäßig für ein halbes Jahr
reichen bei der Ukraine.
Ja, geht auf jeden Fall eine Menge los. Also um mal so eine Größenordnung auch
im Kopf zu haben, Russland produziert offenbar derzeit so 250.000 Artillery Shells im Monat.
Sie haben einfach riesige Produktionskapazitäten dafür aufgebaut in den letzten Jahrzehnten.
Die gesamte EU und die USA produzieren 100.000 Shells pro Monat.
Das ist so die Größenordnung. Also wenn wir jetzt von, so wie Estland das jetzt sozusagen sagt,
sie könnten jetzt für zwei Milliarden US-Dollar Shells beschaffen,
dann entspricht das ungefähr der Jahreskapazität der EU und der USA,
was dort eingekauft wird.
Sollte ich das mal grob durchrechnen.
Ja, und wie vorhin schon erwähnt, also jetzt geht eben auch noch die Suche nach
Patches und ähnlichen Luftabwehrsystemen los.
Das heißt, es werden halt Länder, die viel gekauft haben, denk mal an die arabischen
Staaten, die jetzt vielleicht nicht so den Bedarf, also wenn die 20 Patches
rumstehen haben, dann brauchen sie vielleicht nicht unbedingt alle 20.
So, da kann man ja vielleicht nur hier nochmal zwei und dann nochmal zwei und
so weiter. Kleinvieh macht auch Mist.
Aber es ist halt generell interessant, wie da jetzt Bewegung in diesen ganzen Diskurs reinkommt.
Ja und generell, das müsstest du mir jetzt mal erzählen,
habe ich so den Eindruck, dass während Deutschland so mittlerweile der totale
Buhmann ist, nicht was jetzt insgesamt Lieferungen betrifft,
aber eben was auch die Schwierigkeit des Diskurses überhaupt,
Haupt der Unterstützung betrifft.
Wir hatten das ja hier mit der Taurus-Debatte auch schon ausführlich,
wie schwierig die Rolle von Deutschland da ist im internationalen Vergleich.
Auf der anderen Seite scheint mir aber Tschechien genau auf der anderen Fahrspur
unterwegs zu sein und nicht nur jetzt mit dieser Munitionsaktion,
sondern auch noch mit so einem,
Abhörskandal und entsprechenden Geheimdienstinformationen, die veröffentlicht
wurden. Kannst du mal kurz erklären, was da passiert ist?
Ja, also erstmal, ich meine grundsätzlich wundert mich das ein bisschen,
dass Tschechien sich derart dort profiliert und ins Zeug schmeißt,
weil die Tschechen sind auch eher und waren schon immer eher,
man könnte sagen, pazifistisch veranlagt, man könnte sagen feige oder eben einfach nur ein kleines Land,
wo man so Machtpolitik mit militärischen Mitteln,
man sich nicht wirklich alleine wehren kann gegen all die großen,
übergroßen Nachbarn wie Deutschland.
Auf der einen Seite, ich meine, Tschechien sind es jetzt 10 Millionen Einwohner ungefähr.
Das ist kleiner als Bayern.
Das ist so Baden-Württemberg irgendwie. wie Größenordnung ist nicht kleiner
als Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Und deswegen sind aus irgendwelchen Gründen die Tschechen auch eines der Länder,
die nicht nur mit dem höchsten Bierkonsum, sondern mit der höchsten Rate an Fremdgehen,
sage ich mal.
Also es sind jetzt nicht besonders unbedingt so, wie sagen, treue Seelen oder so.
Deswegen ist es eigentlich, eigentlich ist man eher so mehr auf Genuss bedacht
dort und weniger auf Krieg führen, sag ich mal, oder Stress.
Ich meine, der brave Soldat Schwaig zum Beispiel ist durchaus repräsentativ,
so ein bisschen für die tschechische Volksseele.
Und ich glaube, dass
es derzeit aber vor allem liegt es an der politischen Führung und wo sie da
mit dem Herrn Pavel ja jetzt auch einen Ex-Militär,
der auch so ein bisschen sehr martialisch aussieht, haben.
Und gut, die andere Sache ist natürlich, dass man auch was Russland angeht,
wegen 1968 einfach noch so ein bisschen angefressen ist in Tschechien.
Also der Prager Frühling und ein Marsch der Warschau-Pakt-Truppen und haben
da ein Loch ins Museum geschossen und so. Das war höchst unfreundlich.
So kam nicht gut an.
Loch im Museum, okay.
Ja, deswegen, ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen eine Sondersituation,
eine Sonderkombination.
Die Nation Slowakei ist ja jetzt so ein bisschen wieder in die andere Richtung
nach den Wahlen geraten,
weil dort irgendwelche auch Russland-nahen Populisten jetzt wieder an der Macht sind.
Das könnte in Tschechien auch passieren, aber derzeit zum Glück scheint es eher
den anderen Weg zu fahren und sich da sehr klar ins Zeug zu legen.
Schon vor dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ein großer Rüstungsproduzent.
Das war auch mit ein Grund, warum Hitler damals dort einmarschiert ist,
weil man halt dort die ganzen Rüstungsfabriken, so Škoda und Cezette und so
alle mit haben wollte und war dann auch im Warschauer Pakt ein großer Produzent.
Und da werden ja auch viele Panzer jetzt überholt oder auch in Eigenregie gebaut.
Also ja, insofern hat das Ganze auch eine gewisse industrielle Komponente.
Also man kann unterstützen und man profitiert auch von der Unterstützung wirtschaftlich, denke ich.
Und ja, man hat mit den Russen sowieso noch irgendwie, ja, ein Hühnchen zu rupfen.
Also der Petre Pavel, so heißt er ja, ist der Staatspräsident.
Es gibt ja aber auch noch einen Ministerpräsidenten.
Das ist ja ein anderes Machtverhältnis als wir das jetzt in Deutschland haben
zwischen Präsident und Ministerpräsident.
Also jetzt mal sagen, wer da so die eigentlichen Zügel in der Hand hat.
Also tschechische Politik ist ein bisschen unübersichtlich, sag ich mal.
Und mit Ausnahme der kommunistischen Partei sind alle Parteien,
die du hast, keine Mitgliederparteien.
Sondern die sind relativ klein, was die Mitgliederzahl besteht.
Und die Politiker so tun sich dann immer in irgendwelchen neuen Parteien oder
Gruppierungen zusammen, die sie dann gründen.
Also so ein bisschen Sarah Wagenknecht nur mal fünf oder mal zehn.
Also da herrscht eine andere Dynamik. Und der Präsident hat schon ein bisschen
mehr Einfluss, ist also nicht so repräsentativ wie...
In Deutschland, aber ja, es ist eben auch nicht der Ministerpräsident.
Das ist vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, wie weit man das mit Frankreich vergleichen kann.
Aber ja so richtig ehrlich gesagt blicke ich da auch nicht durch was sich da
entwickelt hat aber es ist eben einfach ein kleineres land so muss muss man
eben sehen vergleichbar mit einem der der größeren deutschen Bundesländer und,
ja,
dementsprechend gibt es auch,
ja, gibt es auch Engpässe bei der Auswahl von politischem Personal,
so wie bei uns in den Bundesländern auch.
Das wollte ich ja gar nicht bezweifeln, mir ging es ja jetzt auch nicht darum,
wie das parteipolitisch aufgebaut ist, sondern jetzt nur so de facto,
Wer entscheidet über diese Außenpolitik?
Ist das jetzt der Ministerpräsident, der auf dem Papier mächtigstes Mitglied
der Exekutive ist, wie die Wikipedia sagt,
oder ist der Staatspräsident da in irgendeiner Form für Außenpolitik mehr zuständig
und bestimmt dort den Weg?
Weil man ist jetzt bei diesem Petre Fiala, der halt der Ministerpräsident ist,
wie herzlich wenig bis gar nichts, also ich habe da zumindest noch nichts gesehen,
aber der Pavel ist halt jetzt die ganze Zeit in der Diskussion.
Ja, er sieht einfach auch cooler aus, finde ich.
Bist du sicher, dass wir uns jetzt hier noch auf der Basis von nachvollziehbaren Argumenten bewegen?
Okay, lassen wir das. Also auf jeden Fall, Tschechien ist sozusagen mit drin
und es gab jetzt aber diesen Abhörskandal oder was war das?
Also wo jetzt rausgekommen ist, was ist dabei rausgekommen?
Ja, also da hat einfach jetzt auch der tschechische Geheimdienst einfach eine
Liste von Politikern, von europäischen Politikern veröffentlicht,
die Gelder von einer russlandfinanzierten Gruppe oder NGO erhalten haben.
Und darunter waren dann eben auch drei deutsche AfD-Politiker,
die auf der Liste standen.
Aber es war halt in ganz Europa Politiker, wo sich Russland eben entsprechend versucht hat.
Freunde zu kaufen oder Freunden, wie auch immer, zu helfen,
mit denen man gemeinsame Interessen teilt.
Und gegebenenfalls Unfrieden
und Unruhe zu sehen im Westen
und eventuell Dinge einfach zu verhindern auf europäischer Ebene und in Europa
und in den einzelnen Ländern dann auch zu spalten oder Opposition gegen die
Unterstützung der Ukraine zu organisieren.
Und sie haben aber wohl
diese Gruppe auch mit entsprechenden
Telekommunikationsabhörmaßnahmen überzogen und haben angeblich Audiobelege für auch deren Treiben.
Und diese sollen wohl kompromittierend sein.
Ich habe da jetzt auch allerdings nichts direkt gehört.
Aber gehe mal davon aus, dass sie nicht einfach irgendwelche zufälligen Namen
in den Raum geworfen haben.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es Meldungen, dass also da sehr viel Geld geflossen ist,
russisches Geld und dass es halt auch teilweise die AfD erreicht hat und man
kann davon ausgehen, dass also nicht nur hier, aber an vielen Stellen,
aber hier ist es jetzt mal sichtbar geworden,
dass eben solche Kanäle in Vielzahl gibt, wo einfach die, ja unsere Demokratie
einfach infiltriert wird, indem halt einfach da Leute bezahlt werden.
Russische Talking Points in der Öffentlichkeit zu vertreten,
also gibt es auch eine Korrektiv Recherche dazu das verlinkt man nochmal,
die das alles untersucht gut, dann schauen wir nochmal kurz auf die Situation mit der USA,
beziehungsweise konkret die Situation mit der NATO, denn wir alle wissen es
droht ja theoretisch eine weitere Trump-Amtszeit.
Das will man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Und ehrlich gesagt, ich lehne das auch nach wie vor ab, das als wahrscheinlich
anzusehen, aber better safe than sorry,
denkt sich wahrscheinlich mittlerweile auch die NATO und nachdem sich Trump
ja auch explizit geäußert hat, so mit ja hier NATO und so, scheiß drauf,
Russland kann ja machen, was sie wollen.
Wir wissen ja alle, wie erratisch dieser Typ ist und mit Sicherheit ist er halt
auch gekauft und dreht frei und hat überhaupt gar kein Verständnis von internationaler
Politik und den Konsequenzen.
Aber Trump hin, Trump her. Interessant ist, wie die NATO jetzt darauf reagiert.
Auf der einen Seite wurde jetzt eine sogenannte NATO-Mission gestartet für die Ukraine.
Die gab es wohl bisher noch nicht. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt sozusagen so eine
definierte Gruppe innerhalb der NATO, die sich um die Ukraine kümmert.
Und es wurde jetzt kolportiert die Idee, ob auch die NATO selber so einen 100
Milliarden Euro Fonds oder Milliarden US Dollar Fonds,
im Prinzip das gleiche, bereitstellen sollte für die Ukraine für die nächsten Jahre.
Das ist sozusagen eine Diskussion. Aber es geht ja noch weiter.
Also die Angst, dass der NATO irgendwie die USA wegbricht durch Trump.
Also dass sozusagen einfach, selbst wenn sie Mitglied sind und bleiben,
man eigentlich nur Störfeuer erwarten kann, geschweige denn irgendeine Unterstützung.
Und da kriegt es natürlich jetzt Europa wirklich mit der Angst,
weil es ist ja klar, wenn man jetzt ohne die USA, weiter ohne die USA hier diesen
Ukraine-Kampf führen möchte,
muss, dann wird es eng.
Weil wir haben nicht genug Waffen, wir haben nicht genug technische Möglichkeiten,
wir haben nicht die Logistik der Amerikaner, im Prinzip hat sich die NATO immer
darauf verlassen, dass es halt die Amerikaner gibt und der Gedanke,
dass die Amerikaner nicht dabei wären, das ist sozusagen schwierig und natürlich
auch so Standorte wie Rammstein gehören dazu,
die ja derzeit noch von der USA geführt werden.
Da gibt es ja sogar die Idee, Rammstein, also den Standort, der wichtigste Standort
der USA in Deutschland unter die Kontrolle der NATO zu bringen.
Ja und dort befindet sich das Hauptquartier der NATO-Luftstreitkräfte.
Also das ist nicht irgendwas, aber es ist eine amerikanische Airbase eben.
So genau und dann gibt es jetzt sagen auch aktuell Überlegungen,
mir ist unklar was das jetzt genau impliziert,
aber man möchte jetzt die NATO Kontrolle über die Airbase so weit ausweiten,
dass im Falle eines Wahlsiegs von Trump dort die US-Einflussnahme begrenzt ist,
also dass sie den nicht einfach zumachen können oder nicht einfach Dinge dann gefährden können.
Also so weit ist man jetzt wohl
angeblich gerade bei der NATO und was die aktuelle US-Regierung angeht.
Tja, also das sind schon interessante Bewegungen.
Ja.
Da ist ein Riesenareal da bei Rammstein, dicker Flughafen.
Ja und ich meine die USA sind nun mal der 900 Pound Gorilla,
was Militär und militärische Fähigkeiten angeht und ohne die Fähigkeiten der
US-Armee so fehlt dem europäischen Militär komplett ein Rückgrat.
Ja, also das ist dann quasi ein Haufen von eher schwabbligen Verbänden,
aber denen es dann an jeder Menge Fähigkeiten fehlt, um integrierten Luftkampf
und Luftverteidigung und so zu führen.
Und es sind auch die Mengen an Munitionen,
Einfach auch gar nicht da. Also da ist man überall derzeit auf die USA angewiesen.
Logistisch auch, weil die Amerikaner einfach weltweit ihre Munition auch an
tausenden Orten dieser Welt verteilt haben.
Ja, und nach wie vor haben die Amerikaner halt 500 Militärbasen weltweit.
Ja, 500. Ich meine, es waren mal über 1000.
Also die haben da auch schon deutlich reduziert. Aber ich glaube,
die nächstgrößeren Länder liegen da im Bereich von vielleicht 10 oder 20 Ländern.
Und die USA ist da einfach auch die einzigen, die wirklich global präsent sind
oder sein können militärisch.
Kein anderes Land kann das in dem Maße.
Und ich denke nur zurück, wie
mühsam das war, als die Engländer die Falklandinseln zurückholen wollten,
wie lange das gedauert hat, bis sie da Schiffe runtergeschickt haben und wie umständlich das war.
Vier Wochen oder so war das.
Ja, ja, also es war lange und es war mühsam und es lief auch alles nicht so richtig gut.
Und seitdem ist aber massiv abgerüstet worden in Europa auch noch.
Also insofern, ja.
Deswegen ist die Situation problematisch. Ich weiß nur nicht,
ob ich das jetzt gut oder schlecht finden soll, was da gerade passiert.
Nämlich, dass Europa
sich jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen mehr auf sich selber besinnen muss und einfach
nicht nur quasi am Zipfel der USA hängt,
weil nicht alles, was aus den USA kommt.
Ist zivilisatorisch gut so unbedingt.
Und ich meine, auf der einen Seite finde ich diese Schwächung der USA,
die da jetzt stattfindet, diese Selbstschwächung, gefährlich und desaströs.
Aber auf der anderen Seite dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen ein Augenöffner
und könnte eben dazu führen,
dass Europa im Endeffekt dadurch politisch mehr zu melden haben wird am Ende des Tages.
Also die Abhängigkeit von den USA zu reduzieren und dort dann auch ein bisschen
selbstbewusster auftreten zu können,
um das mal so zu formulieren.
Das ist die Frage, ob es dann die einzelnen Länder sind, wie es bisher war oder
ob jetzt hier sozusagen auch die EU in irgendeiner Form als Player auftreten wird.
Naja, es ist ja nicht nur dann die EU,
sondern es sind dann auch die NATO-Länder und es gibt etliche andere multinationale
Organisationen, in denen ständig Dinge vereinbart werden.
Und ja, ich bin der Meinung schon,
dass den Amerikanern ein bisschen mehr europäischer Einfluss guttun könnte und
wir in Europa auch mit etwas weniger amerikanischem Einfluss gut klarkommen könnten.
Das ist sehr schwammig ausgedrückt jetzt, aber ich glaube, grundsätzlich.
Aber das liegt vielleicht auch daran, dass ich in Europa aufgewachsen bin,
ist mir das europäische System von allen Systemen, die es so auf der Welt gibt, das sympathischste.
Mit überwiegend Mehrparteien-Systemen, mit Verhältniswahlrecht,
mit einem vernünftigen Sozialsystem, mit einer vom Staat bezahlten Ausbildung,
mit einer Sozialgesetzgebung, wo die Leute einigermaßen Urlaub haben und es
denen eine bessere Work-Life-Balance ermöglicht.
So, aber gut, das mag Geschmackssache sein.
Ja, ist jetzt auch für die militärische Ausrichtung jetzt auch nicht ganz so
super bestimmt für diese Diskussion. Ich weiß schon, worauf du hinaus willst
und ich stimme dir auch dahingehend zu, dass das ganz gut tun würde.
Und ich glaube, das sieht auch mittlerweile Europa so, dass sie jetzt hier in
diesem Spiel, also es ist halt einfach ein Risiko derzeit.
Mit unklarem Ausgang. Es ist ein Risiko, sich komplett darauf zu verlassen,
dass die USA das schon irgendwie regeln wird.
Und weil, wie wir jetzt gerade sehen, ist es halt nicht klar,
ob die USA es regeln wird oder ob die USA komplett wegbricht und jetzt einfach
nur Europa einen Stinkefinger zeigt und sagt, Ukraine interessiert mich einen Scheiß.
Ich meine, es ist alles gegen die Interessen der USA letzten Endes.
Aber Trump interessieren nicht die Interessen der USA, Trump interessieren nur
seine eigenen Interessen, das ist das Problem.
Und dementsprechend sind halt jetzt alle in Aufregung, aber aus dieser Aufregung
kann eben was rauskommen.
Also in dem Zusammenhang muss man auch noch diese Debatte erwähnen,
die jetzt ausgelöst wurde durch Äußerungen von Macron, der sich in diesem ganzen
Konflikt eher erratisch äußert.
Also derzeit ist ja auch die ganze Unterstützung durch Frankreich im Vergleich
zu dem, was jetzt Deutschland liefert
und da haben wir ja schon genug zu kritisieren, gar nicht mal so groß.
Also klar, sie haben auch was geliefert, Hobbitzen und so weiter und sicherlich
das eine oder andere auch noch, aber im Großen und Ganzen sind die Franzosen
nicht im Spiel, auch nicht mit ihrer Luftwaffe und auch nicht in einem nennenswerten Maße.
Nichtsdestotrotz hat aber Macron jetzt auch so ein bisschen seinen Ton gewechselt
und hat halt in Äußerungen davon gesprochen,
man dürfe eben nichts ausschließen in Bezug auf die Frage,
ob es denn irgendwann mal NATO-Truppen in der Ukraine geben sollte.
Das hat jetzt eine ganz interessante Auswirkung gehabt, natürlich allen voran
die SPD hat dann erstmal sofort,
also die deutsche Regierung hat dann halt sofort gesagt, so ja nee Quatsch und
das geht ja gar nicht und Eskalation und Pipapo,
was man halt jetzt schon kennt.
Also da sind sozusagen echte Konfliktlinien zwischen Frankreich und Deutschland zu sehen.
Aber andere Länder wie Norwegen zum Beispiel haben gesagt, wir schließen das halt auch nicht aus.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch an der Stelle ein ganz interessanter Aspekt,
dass man vielleicht in einem Krieg mit so einem anderen Land,
was irgendwie keinerlei Grenzen kennt in seiner Brutalität und sich auch von
Menschenrechten und anderen Reglementarien überhaupt nicht auch nur im Ansatz aufhalten lässt,
dass man dann nicht irgendwie im Wesentlichen die ganze Debatte darüber führt,
indem man öffentlich verkündet, was man alles nicht tun wird.
Also ich meine, wenn jetzt irgendwie einer auf dich losgeht und irgendwie auf
dich einprügelt und du sagst so Ja, aber ich werde auf gar keinen Fall zurückschlagen weil Gründe,
Dann freut die Person sich und weißt du, okay, alles klar, da kann ich jetzt
draufhauen bis zum Get-No, weil schlägt ja nicht zurück.
Ich weiß nicht, wie siehst du diese Boots on the Ground Debatte generell und
hältst du es für möglich, dass wir da auch nochmal konkreter werden?
Also ich halte die Politik, sich eigene rote Linien zu setzen für potenziell kontraproduktiv.
Ich kann eine gewisse Anti-Eskalations-Politik durchaus sehen oder finde,
ja, man will vielleicht nicht unbedingt eskalieren oder Eskalation vermeiden.
Aber meine Sicht ist, dass das der falsche Weg ist Und dass eben Frankreich
mit seiner Politik der strategischen Ambiguität.
Zumindest jetzt mal erreicht hat, dass der Scheugu sich bei seinem französischen
Amtskollegen gemeldet hat Die haben seit Ausbruch des Krieges,
seit über einem Jahr war da Funkstille Und plötzlich redet man zumindest miteinander.
Ich war jetzt nicht dabei und vermutlich hat Scheugu irgendwelche Drohungen
überbracht, würde ich mal vermuten.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz gab es plötzlich wieder direkte Kommunikation auf hoher Ebene.
Und ich denke auch, es macht keinen Sinn, Dinge unbedingt vom Tisch zu nehmen.
Aber strategisch ist es so, dass...
Man ein gewisses Eskalationspotenzial haben will,
um eben Eskalation zu vermeiden, weil wenn ich kein eigenes Eskalationspotenzial habe,
hindert ja nichts die andere Seite daran, einfach so zu eskalieren, wie sie gerne möchte.
Ohne negative Dinge befürchten zu müssen.
Und so die Hoffnung oder das Überlegen, was so im Kopf von Scholz und seinen
Beratern wahrscheinlich dort vor sich geht,
ich meine genau drin stecke ich nicht, aber das Einzige, wie ich mir das erklären
kann, ist, dass sie sich sagen,
wir wollen das nicht unnötig anheizen, die Situation, weil wir wissen dann nicht,
was passiert und wir wollen uns ein bisschen Eskalationspotenzial erhalten und glauben,
das hindert die Russen an Eskalation oder umgekehrt, dass man glaubt,
wenn wir jetzt alles reinwerfen, was wir haben, dann können die Russen nicht anders,
als dann selber eine Schippe draufzulegen.
So ja, das ist glaube ich die Logik, was im Kopf der Leute vor sich geht und ich halte das,
und man kann das auch nicht völlig von der Hand weisen, dass auch bei den Russen natürlich.
Also da ginge noch mehr.
Ja, Ukraine und Russland sind nicht im totalen Krieg, beide Seiten nicht.
Also auf beiden Seiten ist die Zahl der Grausamkeiten.
Die man dem eigenen Volk und dem Kriegsgegner antun könnte, ist noch deutlich ausbaufähig.
Es ist nicht so, dass, ich meine, und wir haben das ja jetzt insofern gesehen,
also beide Seiten tun sich ja ernsthaft weh, jetzt kann man sagen.
Ja, kann man sagen. Tun die Russen den Ukrainern ein bisschen mehr weh,
aber im Großen und Ganzen, also kann man einfach festhalten,
beide Seiten tun sich gegenseitig mehr weh, als man das jetzt auf Jahrzehnte
hinaus aushalten könnte.
So ist, glaube ich, die Situation. Aber auch
beide Seiten haben eben noch Eskalationspotenzial und der Westen genauso.
Und ja, was jetzt Deutschlands Rolle angeht, wünschte ich mir auch.
Es wäre eine andere Regierung oder eine andere Regierungspolitik zumindest angesagt.
Und was nicht unbedingt legitim ist, ist zusätzlich, dass die Politik den Leuten noch Angst macht,
dass Olaf Scholz rumrennt oder dass irgendjemand aus unserer politischen Führungsriege
russischer Propaganda einfach auch noch ein Outlet gibt.
Das muss nicht sein.
Ich erwarte eigentlich von der Regierung, dass sie sich da von Drohungen unbeeindruckt
zeigt und nicht noch eigene Ängste, die vielleicht da sind,
auch noch dann jetzt weiter verbreitet.
Ja, also die Art und Weise, wie Deutschland das auch gekontert hat,
war dann ohnehin nicht sonderlich glücklich,
weil in den ganzen Statements, die dann abgegeben wurden von Scholz,
Mützenich und so weiter, kam dann,
ich glaube vor allem bei Scholz kam dann eben auch noch so dieser Hinweis drauf,
ja wir können ja jetzt hier nicht wie die Engländer da so vor Ort rumhängen.
Es war jetzt nicht wörtlich zitiert, aber aus den Äußerungen kam im Prinzip eine Bestätigung.
Also ihr Redebeitrag zu der Frage, soll Deutschland oder soll die NATO oder irgendwer, wir,
dort Soldaten in der Ukraine haben, die quasi dort hauptamtlich der Ukraine helfen.
Die Formulierungen, die dann gewählt wurden, haben relativ klar durchscheinen
lassen, so nach dem Motto, ja wir können es ja nicht machen wie die Engländer,
dass die Briten dort sind.
So, ich meine, jeder der da ist, weiß das.
Also wir hatten das auch schon in diesem Taurus-Gespräch, kam das ja auch zur
Sprache mit den Leuten, die da rumlaufen und einen auffallenden amerikanischen
Akzent haben und so weiter.
Also es ist klar, Briten und Amerikaner haben militärisches Personal in Kiew
oder wo auch immer am Start und helfen.
Die helfen auf irgendeine Art und Weise, wir wissen es nicht.
Wir wissen nicht, ob die bei den Storm Shadow Einsätzen helfen,
wir wissen nicht, ob das sozusagen nur Kontakte sind, die vor Ort gehalten werden,
um diese ganze Intelligenz auszutauschen.
Die Flugbeobachtung etc. Zielauswahl, also niemand weiß, wie weit das geht,
aber es ist halt klar, dass es so ist.
Trotzdem waren die Briten nicht besonders amused über diese Äußerung,
weil sie damit sozusagen den diplomatischen Geflogenheiten einfach komplett
eins vor den Kopf gegeben haben.
Es war einfach diplomatisch eine Vollkatastrophe und darüber hinaus eben halt
auch wieder so ein weiterer Beitrag in dem, was wir alles irgendwie nicht tun werden.
Naja, es ist In der Praxis gibt es
da schon sehr entscheidende rechtliche Unterschiede, wenn du jetzt sagst,
die Engländer oder wir schicken jetzt Militär.
Was wir ja schon lange haben, ist, dass Staatsbürger anderer Länder auch im
ukrainischen Militär dienen und dort helfen und unterstützen.
Klar, aber nicht mit dem Kommando.
Funktion des französischen Staates ausübt, dann ist es eben eine Gepflogenheit,
dass diese Person dann akkreditiert wird und mit einem Diplomatenpass einreist
und damit auch gewisse Rechte und Immunität vor Strafverfolgung und Ähnlichem so hat.
Wenn jetzt einfach,
Irgendein Engländer oder irgendein Franzose in der Ukraine einreist,
dann ist er da erstmal Tourist.
So mit allen Pflichten und Rechten und dazwischen gibt es dann jetzt nicht unbedingt allzu viel.
Die Frage ist immer, wessen hoheitliche Funktion wird dort eigentlich ausgeübt
und das braucht eben einen rechtlichen Rahmen und da sind alle Staaten auch nur so mittelflexibel.
Das ist nicht so Wildwest, wie man glauben möchte.
Aber ich meine, ich rede ja jetzt auch nicht so sehr von den diplomatischen Details,
die das hat, sondern die Frage, die ja hier im Raum steht, ist,
werden wir mit unserem eigenen Truppen, ob das fünf Leute sind, 50, 500,
5000 oder 50.000, völlig egal, Egal, werden wir
mit Truppen aus der NATO
in diesem Krieg irgendwann präsent sein und wird sozusagen ein militärisches
Kommando eines der Mitgliedsländer der NATO oder eben am Ende sogar die NATO
selbst in irgendeiner Form einen Einsatz koordinieren.
Und es gibt ja auch verschiedene Ansätze, was das sein könnte.
Das bedeutet ja jetzt nicht sofort, Deutschland die Front,
um es mal extrem zu sagen, sondern es könnten ja auch so Sachen sein wie,
die NATO entsendet eine Mission zur Sicherung der Nordgrenze.
Ja, also dieses ganze Gebiet westlich von Kiew sagen wir mal oder eben vielleicht
auch östlich von Kiew, was auch immer.
Also wenn dort eine NATO-Truppenpräsentation, also westlich von Kiew ist im
Wesentlichen ein verhältnismäßig befriedeter Bereich.
Also Befried ist vielleicht auch nicht das richtige Wort, aber dort gibt es
gerade keine militärischen Aktionen mit der Ausnahme von eben Raketenbeschuss,
der das ganze Land trifft.
Ähnliches könnte man eben auch für andere Regionen sagen. Zum Beispiel die Grenze
nach Moldawien, also gut, dann kommen wir noch in dieses Problem Transnistrien
mit rein, das sprechen wir auch gleich nochmal kurz an,
aber es sind ja auch alles jetzt nur Ansätze, um zu sagen, man muss ja nicht
unbedingt ins Kriegsgeschehen eingreifen, aber man kann ja zum Beispiel auch
dadurch Unterstützung liefern, indem man die Ukraine sozusagen entlastet.
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt so was zu sagen hätte, wenn ich jetzt die deutsche Außenpolitik,
die europäische irgendwie koordinieren würde.
Was wäre dann?
Ja, ich würde ganz klar an Russland signalisieren, Leute, ihr wisst,
wir können uns das nicht leisten, dass ihr gewinnt in der Ukraine.
Das ist ein komplettes No-Go. Und wir gucken uns das Ganze jetzt ganz genau an.
Und wenn ihr einfach zu krass seid, wenn ihr zu erfolgreich seid,
dann werden wir eingreifen.
Und je erfolgreicher ihr seid, umso mehr werden wir unsere Anstrengungen steigern.
Und es gibt, was das Steigern unserer Anstrengungen angeht, keine Obergrenze.
Und wenn alle Stricke reißen, wenn ihr die Ukraine überrennen solltet und uns
hier 20 Millionen Flüchtlinge drohen,
dann werden wir das stoppen.
Mit allen Mitteln, die uns zur Verfügung stehen.
Da gibt es keine Tabus. Und der Punkt ist,
das wäre aus meiner Sicht keine Drohung, keine leere Drohung,
keine, die aus der Luft gezogen ist, sondern das ist so, wie es faktisch laufen würde,
wenn...
Wenn Russland jetzt plötzlich anfängt, die Ukraine zu überrennen,
dann sehe ich ohnehin, sagen keine roten Linien.
Und die Frage ist, ob man nicht genau sowas auch vielleicht nicht öffentlich
an Russland durchaus signalisiert und vielleicht ein bisschen freundlicher das Ganze sagt.
Ihr wisst ja, in manchen Dingen sind uns die Hände gebunden und wenn ihr,
dann können wir halt nicht anders.
Aber die öffentliche Kommunikation in Deutschland finde ich auf der einen Seite
verständlich, weil deutsche Politik ist darauf ausgerichtet,
es irgendwie allen recht machen zu wollen.
Und wenn man sich dann anguckt, was Deutschland tut, ist tatsächlich irgendwie
allen Seiten Krümel hinzuwerfen.
Oder vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr als Krümel.
Bei Unterstützung für die Ukraine ist ja da, man gibt Geld,
man liefert Waffen, bestimmte Waffenkategorien und gleichzeitig aber blockt
man und wirft halt Russland andere Krümel hin,
indem man dann eben auch rote Linien zieht oder sich dann zurückhält mit bestimmter Unterstützung.
Und deswegen, wenn man sich dann die Politik anguckt, kann keiner so richtig glücklich damit sein.
Also auch Russland ist ja nicht glücklich mit der deutschen Politik,
aber genauso wenig ist es die Ukraine.
Und jetzt könnte man sagen, ja super, weil es ist doch toll,
aber ich glaube, es kostet uns unnötig viel Geld und es ist einfach gefährlich,
was wir hier tun und nicht besonders vertrauenerweckend.
So, das ist meine Wahrnehmung. Und ja, okay.
Ich möchte das jetzt gar nicht weiter fortführen, aber diese Diskussion wird
uns sicherlich noch einfangen, da bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Tja, jetzt müssen wir uns aber nochmal kurz zu diesem Kroko-City-Terroranschlag
äußern. Das ist ja auch noch passiert. Am 23.
März 2024 gab es halt einen Angriff auf diese Kroko-City-Hall.
Das ist so ein Veranstaltungszentrum im Nordosten Moskaus.
Und das ist auch so ein kompletter Komplex. Also da gibt es irgendwie dieses
Krogo City Hall und dann gibt es glaube ich auch noch eine Krogo City Mall und so.
Also da ist auf jeden Fall einiges angesiedelt und dort hat ein Konzert stattgefunden
mit vielen tausend Besuchern.
Und dort sind dann vermutlich vier Angreifer reinmarschiert,
bewaffnet und hatten dann die Möglichkeit dort sehr lange mit Waffen auf die
Anwesenden zu schießen.
Dabei sind irgendwie hunderte ums Leben gekommen und viele sind verletzt worden.
Dann wurden die auch nicht vor Ort aufgebracht, sondern sind wohl,
ist ihnen noch gelungen mit dem Auto zu fliehen und tatsächlich auch Moskau
zu verlassen und das Ganze in Richtung Westen,
so wie es dann später vom Kreml dargestellt wurde, in Richtung Ukraine.
Ukraine, was naja eine interessante Formulierung ist, weil der Ort,
wo sie aufgefunden wurden,
das war dann in so einem Wald, der Luftlinie so 15 Kilometer entfernt war von
der Grenze nach Belarus.
Belarus und es ist dann doch eher wahrscheinlich, dass sie, wenn überhaupt sie
einen Grenzübertritt geplant haben, dann den Richtung Belarus vorgehabt haben
und nicht Richtung Ukraine,
weil ich glaube, wenn du jetzt ein Terrorist bist und du fließt gerade vor den russischen Entitäten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob so eine Frontlinie mit einem Kriegspartner gerade,
wo sozusagen Russland die ganze Grenze entlang mit Militär steht,
was die ganze Zeit diesen Bereich bewacht, ob das so der beste Ort ist, um irgendwo zu fliehen.
Später und das auch recht bald hat sich dann eine Organisation namens IS,
naja ISIS aber halt, also ISIS als solches gibt es ja in dem Sinne so jetzt nicht mehr.
Sondern das ist halt
aufgebrochen in so verschiedene Untergruppen und
diese Untergruppe nennt sich ISK und also ISIS-Khorasan und das ist so ein afghanischer Ableger.
Macht halt das, was irgendwie alle diese Terrorgruppen halt machen.
Sie werben halt, versuchen halt Leute anzuwerben für Terroranschläge und für
ihre Sache und Amerika ist der Böse und Russland ist aber mittlerweile auch der Böse.
Der ISK steht sozusagen auch im Kampf mit den Taliban.
Also das ist jetzt immer nicht alles so einfach.
Immer die ISIS, beziehungsweise hinterher haben sie sich ja selber IS oder islamischer
Staat genannt, ist insofern wirklich eine sehr bemerkenswerte Organisation,
als dass sie es geschafft haben, sich wirklich jeden zum Feind zu machen.
Normalerweise ist es ja der Feind meines Feindes Mechanismen,
die dann zu seltsamen Konstellationen führen, aber die.
Und ISIS oder der IS hat es halt geschafft,
auch durch seine unglaubliche Brutalität und aber auch einfach durch seinen
generellen, also die Leute waren einfach so extrem,
dass sie es sich geschafft, dass sie nicht nur geschafft haben,
haben sich die ganzen USA und den Westen,
sondern halt auch Russland, auch China,
auch den Iran und so Hisbollah und wirklich alle und inklusive der Taliban jetzt.
Also wenn quasi du wirklich plötzlich deine Feinde, die USA und die Taliban
und Russland und China und Iran umfassen und wahrscheinlich auch Nordkorea oder so,
dann bist du wirklich außerhalb von allem unterwegs,
was irgendwie diese Länder vereint.
Also es ist jedenfalls, also ja, alle hassen den IS.
Und deswegen ist es aber auch gelungen, ihn zurückzudrängen und sagen,
ja jetzt in ein paar Pockets, also ihn eigentlich zu zerschlagen.
Weil alle, aber auch wirklich alle dagegen waren.
Ja, aber man muss halt schon klar machen, das ist halt jetzt mehr so ein IS-Brand,
der hier ist und der von unterschiedlichen Gruppen, sowohl in Afrika als eben
auch in Afghanistan und auch in anderen Gegenden verwendet wird, die aber so.
Organisatorisch erstmal nichts miteinander zu tun haben, also zumindest nicht
unmittelbar, also da gibt es keine gemeinsame Führungs- und Kommandostruktur etc.
Dieser ISIS-K ist halt irgendwie nochmal so eine besonders krasse Abteilung
und naja, Afghanistan, man kann sich das schon vorstellen,
dadurch, dass die halt aber auch quasi im Kampf, also der IS im Kampf mit Russland
stand, ist halt Russland auch ein erkanntes Ziel dieser Organisation.
Organisation und sie haben sich ja nicht nur dazu bekannt, sondern sie haben
dann halt auch Aufnahmen dieser vier Attentäter, die offensichtlich das durchgeführt haben,
also die hatten sozusagen vorher Aufnahmen von denen und haben die dann veröffentlicht,
womit eigentlich auch relativ klar ist, dass also hier die Ursache nicht in
der Ukraine zu suchen ist.
Natürlich hat Putin trotzdem versucht, diesen ganzen Anschlag der Ukraine in
irgendeiner Form in die Schuhe zu schieben, wie zum Beispiel mit dieser Formulierung,
sie hätten sich ja in die Richtung Ukraine absetzen wollen und wie das dann
eben so ist mit russischer Propaganda,
wenn dann halt tausend Sachen veröffentlicht und dann wird halt mal dies behauptet,
mal das behauptet, damit bloß keiner weiß, wo oben und unten ist.
Trotz alledem glaubt es halt in Russland keiner.
Also es ist einfach diese Argumentation, die Ukraine würde jetzt hinter diesem
Terroranschlag stecken, dass es also auch den härtesten Propagandisten nicht so richtig gelungen,
da eine schlüssige Kette, Logikette herzustellen, weil es halt einfach nicht passt.
Und man kann insofern davon ausgehen, dass dieser Anschlag halt genau das war.
Nämlich ein Anschlag des ISK und es gab einen sehr zögerlichen Einsatz der Sicherheitskräfte,
was sich halt daran festmachen lässt, dass sie eben nicht vor Ort eingekesselt
wurden und der ganze Vorgang in dieser Coco City Hall wohl auch recht lange gedauert hat.
Ich glaube, die waren da irgendwie 90 Minuten irgendwie am werkeln und in dieser
Zeit haben es die Sicherheitskräfte halt nicht geschafft, derer habhaft zu werden.
Die haben die dann halt erst, wie gesagt, kurz vor der Belarus-Grenze aufgegriffen,
aber dort dann natürlich auch alles gleich mit gefilmt.
Und dann haben sie irgendwie dem einen noch ein Ohr abgeschnitten und irgendwie
zum Essen vorgehalten und so weiter.
Was halt auch ein Grad an Verrohung auf dem Staatslevel ist,
der auch nochmal für sich spricht.
Also nicht nur, dass das passiert ist. Nein, es wurde auch gefilmt,
es wurde veröffentlicht.
Und dann haben sie auch noch diese Terroristen in ihrem völlig lidierten Zustand.
Der eine im Rollstuhl, die da in aller Aus, als wenn sie reif für die Intensivstation.
Sozusagen nach dem Haftrichter vorgeführt und das Ganze auch noch im Fernsehen übertragen.
Einschließlich des Typens mit dem abgeschnittenen Ohr. Und das ist aber auch
jetzt nicht irgendwie passiert,
sondern dieses Ohr abschneiden, das hat halt auch noch so diesen Hintergrund,
also soweit ich das verstanden habe,
speziell so bei bei Islamisten das eben auch nochmal so eine Sache ist,
weil irgendwie, was weiß ich, wenn du irgendwie dann Märtyrer wirst,
dann wirst du von Allah an den Ohren irgendwie in den Himmel gezogen und wenn
du deine Ohren nicht hast, egal,
ich bin kein Experte, was ich nur sagen möchte ist, da hat sich diese russische
Seite einfach auch, einfach überhaupt nicht.
Nicht professionell verhalten, aber sozusagen, da war gar kein Halten mehr,
was dort an Brutalität gezeigt wurde,
um irgendwie diesen Eindruck zu erwecken, man wäre ja jetzt irgendwie Herr der Situation.
Und das ist eigentlich genau das Problem für Putin, dieser Terroranschlag ist
für die Regierung eigentlich ein totales Problem. Problem.
Gab ja sehr schnell und wir haben ja auch kurz darüber geschrieben,
als das passiert ist, noch gar nicht so richtig klar war, war ja so die Frage,
ja false flag oder nicht,
also wird jetzt hier so ein Terroranschlag zelebriert und dann wird es der Ukraine
in die Schuhe geschoben, um sozusagen den nächsten Level der Mobilisierung zu machen,
das war ja so eine Theorie, die schnell draußen war, aber dann einfach überhaupt nicht getragen hat,
einfach weil einfach die ganze Faktenlage so offensichtlich anders war.
Und man merkt ja auch immer daran, dass es kein volles Fleck ist,
wenn sozusagen die ganzen Propagandamedien nicht sofort auch irgendwie einen
passenden Text am Start haben.
Also die haben alle rumgerudert und wussten erstmal gar nichts zu sagen.
Putin selber hat sich erst so nach 19 Stunden überhaupt zu dem Fall öffentlich
gemeldet und man merkte einfach sofort, das ist etwas, was sie nicht auf dem
Zettel hatten und das ist darüber hinaus auch etwas, was für sie ein Problem ist.
Weil natürlich dieses ganze Diktatorengetue mit ich bin hier euer Chef und ihr
habt mich mit 87,5 Prozent gewählt,
weil ich biete euch ja was an und das Angebot ist, ihr seid sicher.
So euch kann nichts passieren, nur die anderen haben zu leiden und das wird
natürlich mit solchen Terroranschlägen total konterkariert.
Ja, ja. Nee, und ich meine, der ausschlaggebende Punkt war ja,
dass einfach IS diese Propagandakanäle dann tatsächlich das Material veröffentlicht haben.
Also Insider-Material, wo klar war, okay,
wer immer diese Medienkanäle kontrolliert, hatte vorher Wissen von diesem Anschlag
und alles, was bis dato aus diesen Kanälen kam,
klang halt nach eben ISK.
Also da gab es jetzt auch keine Zweifel daran, dass es vorher ISK-Kanäle waren.
Auf der anderen Seite, bei Terroranschlägen,
Und ich habe mir mal die Mühe gemacht und bin alle Terroranschläge in der Wikipedia
durchgegangen und habe dann eine Strichliste gemacht,
bei wie vielen davon eine Beteiligung irgendeines Staates oder eines Geheimdienstes
dort nachgewiesen war und wo nichts dergleichen erwähnt war.
Und über die Hälfte aller Terroranschläge, die dort in der Wikipedia standen,
das waren über 100, fast 200, die ich ausgewertet habe.
In welchem Zeitraum?
So in den letzten 50 Jahren oder so.
Also ich bin nicht jetzt ins 19. Jahrhundert zurückgegangen.
Ja, okay, wollte nochmal eine Größenordnung haben.
Und also überwiegend nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg eigentlich.
Nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg habe ich glaube ich die Grenze gesetzt.
Und ja, wie gesagt, deswegen ist, wenn irgendwo ein Terroranschlag passiert,
ist es jetzt nicht unvernünftig, eine Verschwörung in Betracht zu ziehen,
weil eben, also sprich, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass irgendwie eine staatliche,
ein Staat oder sein Geheimdienst das irgendwie gefördert hat, ist groß.
Aber ich habe deswegen eben die Geschichte von IS und ISIS erzählt,
wie sie es sich wirklich mit allen verscherzt haben.
Ja, das heißt, die würden auch nicht jetzt, also es ist einfach nicht anzunehmen,
dass es irgendjemanden gibt, selbst die Taliban,
also die Russen und die Taliban haben sich jetzt zusammengetan unter anderem.
Um den IS zu bekämpfen oder die IS-Reste zu bekämpfen und mit den Amerikanern.
Und die würden wahrscheinlich sogar zusammen mit der Ukraine die Russen den
IS bekämpfen, wenn es darauf ankäme.
Und deshalb bin ich auch der Meinung, aus dieser ganzen Konstellation, es ist, was es ist.
Es war halt irgendeine IS-Splitter-Terrororganisation.
Auch, ich meine, es ist ja sehr ähnlich dem Bataclan-Anschlag in Paris, so 2015 oder so.
Ja, November 2015, wo da auch in einem Theater bei einem Musikfestival der IS
über 100 Leute erschossen hat.
Und ja, im Grunde genommen war das fast eine Kopie und es ist aber auch das
Horrorszenario für jede Sicherheitsbehörde,
auf das gut wie kein Staat vorbereitet ist, ist,
wenn eine kleine bis mittlere Gruppe an Leuten ausgerüstet mit militärischen
Waffen koordiniert versucht,
einfach Menschen zu erschießen.
Das ist quasi wie ein Amoklauf, nur dass du in dem Fall ein taktisches Team
mit Kriegswaffen hast, das einen Amoklauf in einer Stadt begeht.
Und sich dann eventuell auch noch ein Ziel aussucht wie eine Massenveranstaltung.
Da kannst du tun und lassen, was du willst.
Da machst du auch nichts, wenn jetzt vier Leute mit Sturmgewehren auf deine
Security losgehen am Stadion oder so.
Da machst du halt auch nicht viel. Viel.
Und deshalb.
Aber was so erwähnt ist, dass sich dort die russischen Sicherheitsbehörden in
Moskau, obwohl, es ist sogar eine Polizeistation in dem Gebäude.
Polizeistation in Gebäude, das ist auch ein Standort, also ein großer Standort
der Spezialkräfte in der Nähe.
Also was da schief gegangen ist, das steht nochmal auf einem anderen Blatt.
Aber man kann halt auch festhalten...
Russland, ein Land, wo du sozusagen keine fünf Minuten auf einem öffentlichen
Platz, wahrscheinlich auch keine 50 Sekunden auf einem öffentlichen Platz stehen
kannst, mit einem weißen Blatt in der Hand und du sofort irgendwie abgeführt wirst,
ist darauf optimiert, die Bevölkerung zu überwachen, dass sie irgendwie politisch
mitgeht, aber hat sozusagen die
eigentlichen Schutz komplett hinten angestellt, wie es den Eindruck hat.
Und was wir auch noch nicht erwähnt hatten, die USA hatten ja auch gewarnt,
hatten öffentlich ja auch gewarnt.
Allerdings geht man davon aus, dass der Anschlag daraufhin verschoben wurde,
nachdem die USA öffentlich gewarnt hatten. Und Putin hat das ja als Drohung abgewiesen.
Aber jetzt ist auch noch rausgekommen, dass der Iran wohl auch gewarnt hat.
Allerdings nicht öffentlich, sondern halt heimlich. Das heißt,
sie waren auch noch, nicht nur durch die USA, sondern auch noch durch den Iran
gewarnt vor dem Terroranschlag.
Und deswegen ist auch eine Vermutung, dass sie es opportun fanden,
den Anschlag passieren zu lassen.
Ja, also, dass sie den zwar jetzt nicht selber inszeniert haben,
also in dem Sinne, dass es kein false flag war, sondern ISIS das auch gemacht
hat, aber man sich entschieden hat,
naja, gucken wir doch mal und das nutzen wir lieber für uns.
Also sozusagen kein Terroranschlag.
Ja, also das Gerücht gab es natürlich auch,
aber dann glaube ich haben sie wahrscheinlich die Konsequenzen dieses Terroranschlags
unterschätzt und sind eher davon ausgegangen, dass da weniger passiert,
das wäre ihnen dann egal gewesen, aber so ist es natürlich ein Fanal und wenn
das die Kalkulation war, was wir nicht wissen und wahrscheinlich nie wissen
werden, dann war es keine gute Aktion.
Ich halte es auch für unwahrscheinlich, aber es würde dann zumindest ein paar
andere Merkwürdigkeiten mit erklären,
aber für diese Merkwürdigkeiten reicht halt auch Inkompetenz als Erklärung völlig aus.
Weswegen man diese kompliziertere Erklärung nicht braucht und ja,
wahrscheinlich war es der übliche Fuck-up, so nach dem Motto,
ja gut, wir haben hier eine Warnung, aber hm,
naja gut, ja.
Was aber mit ziemlicher Sicherheit ein False Flag war, ist ein Angriff auf einen
Hubschrauber in Transnistrien.
Also das ist so eine Sache, die kam vor zwei Wochen raus.
Da gab es halt einen Angriff auf einen geparkten Hubschrauber in Transnistrien.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau wo, aber ich vermute mal in der Hauptstadt.
Wie heißt die nochmal gleich? Siraspol.
Und das wirkte sofort total fishy.
Also es macht sozusagen den Eindruck, als ob hier ein Angriff durchgeführt worden
wäre auf militärisches Gerät der Russen in Transnistrien.
Also wer nicht weiß, was Transnistrien ist, Transnistrien ist so ein schmaler
Streifen an der Ostseite Moldawiens, der sich abgespalten hat und zu diesen
nicht anerkannten Staaten gehört,
die sich halt in irgendeiner Form Russland zugewendet haben.
Ähnliches gibt es ja mit Abkhazien und mit Süd-Ossetien in Georgien.
Dort sind die Russen ja auch stark präsent. Sie sind auch in Transnistrien präsent,
allerdings nicht stark und hatten sicherlich auch Schwierigkeiten hier in irgendeiner
Form für Personalaustausch zu sorgen in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Nichtsdestotrotz sind sie halt noch dort und sind ein Problem Transnistrien und Moldawien,
sind jetzt sagen wir mal auch kulturell nicht so nah beieinander der Großteil von Moldawien,
ist ja eigentlich eher oder versteht sich auch selbst glaube ich eher als Teil
Rumäniens und es kann sehr wohl sein, dass wir irgendwann.
So eine Art Anschluss oder Wiedervereinigung, wie man es auch mal nennen möchte,
von Moldawien und Rumänien.
Also ich sage nicht, das wird passieren, aber es würde mich nicht wundern,
weil es sozusagen zwei Länder sind, die ähnliche Sprache haben und kulturell
einfach so miteinander verwoben sind, dass das schon Teil der politischen Diskussion ist.
Aber das wird natürlich gerade durch diese Abspaltung Transnistrien,
was ja dann auch offiziell zu Moldawien gehört, natürlich auch unter anderem
auch deshalb erschwert.
Und das liegt natürlich dann eben auch, ist dann sozusagen die komplette Ostgrenze
oder ein Großteil der Ostgrenze Moldawiens zur Ukraine ist eben dieses Transnistrien.
Und es gingen jetzt auch Gerüchte rum, dass man dort so eine Abstimmung machen
will über die Unabhängigkeit, also genauso wie man das in den anderen Ländern
auch schon gesehen hat. Und dazu gab es dann auf einmal noch dieses Bild von diesem Hubschrauber.
Problem ist nur, und deswegen sage ich auch, das war jetzt definitiv so eine
Volksfleck-Nummer, dieser Hubschrauber stand da schon irgendwie seit 10 Jahren kaputt rum.
Also der war nicht irgendwie im Einsatz und stand da jetzt irgendwie seit einem
Tag und ist dann von irgendjemand angegriffen worden.
Außerdem war das eine Überwachungskamera Die diesen Vorgang gefilmt hat Das
Ding ist ja auch sofort komplett ausgebrannt.
Und Es gab so ein Full HD, beste Qualität Video Mitschnitt Wie der halt irgendwie
Zerfetzt wurde Und ich meine wir haben schon,
Einiges gesehen in diesem Krieg, aber dass irgendwie es so eine Full-Quality-Kamera
die ganze Zeit auf einem seit 10 Jahren rumstehenden, also man weiß das aus Satellitenbildern,
seit 10 Jahren rumstehenden kaputten Hubschrauber gerichtet ist und dann irgendwie
so ein Angriff mitgeschnitten wird, das ist dann doch sehr,
sehr, sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Also es gibt so verschiedenste Versuche immer wieder von Russland in Transnistrien
in irgendeiner Form für Aufregung zu sorgen.
Ob sie da wirklich jetzt einen langfristigen Plan haben, wissen wir nicht.
Aber es ist klar, wäre es den Russen gelungen Odessa zu nehmen und dann nach
Osten weiter vorzustoßen.
Wir hätten den Anschluss Transnistriens an das russische Reich schon längst gesehen.
Ja und sie hätten dann, ja und in Moldawien liegen ja auch noch sozusagen Hermann Görings Weinkeller,
den haben sie da auch sozusagen als Kriegsbeute eingelagert,
weil der Wein ist einfach hervorragend.
Also Moldawien und der Wein, der dort gemacht wird, ist,
ja, also, und wie gesagt,
die haben dort die größten Weinkeller der Welt mit zu 20 Millionen eingelagerten
Flaschen und unter anderem eben haben sie dann dort auch Hermann Görings Weinkeller hintransferiert.
Okay. Ja, naja. Also das war definitiv eine False Flag.
Warum ich das überhaupt erwähne, ist halt, Transnistrien wird in diesem ganzen
Konflikt oft ausgeblendet, weil da natürlich jetzt auch erstmal nicht so viel passiert ist.
Und trotzdem ist das natürlich ein Problem.
Es ist ein Problem für einen möglichen Beitritt Moldawiens in die EU. Es ist ein,
entsprechender Problemfaktor für auch auch einen Anschluss an Rumänien,
wenn das sozusagen politisch geboten sein sollte.
Und militärisch kann sich natürlich der derzeit gar nichts lösen,
aber man sieht, Russland rüttelt einfach an allen Kabeln.
Also die lassen nichts unversucht, um in irgendeiner Form Europa aus der Spur zu bringen.
Die hassen uns einfach und das ist echt ein Problem.
Ja, und das macht auch nur Probleme irgendwie im Fußball so,
weil Tiraspol muss irgendwie unter, wenn es dann an ausländischen Wettbewerben
teilnimmt oder dort geladen ausländische Mannschaften kommen,
müssen sie unter moldawischer Nationalhymne und Flagge auf dem Trikot spielen,
was dann auch immer für viel Verstimmung sorgt.
Also es ist einfach nur Chaos.
Wie überall.
Dort, ja.
Alright. So, was haben wir noch? Ähm...
Ich habe mir, also Perun ist ja, wir hatten ja irgendwann mal so eine Übersicht
gemacht über gute Kanäle auf YouTube und andere Quellen.
Einer davon ist Perun und der hat mal wieder einen sehr interessanten Einblick
geliefert in die Situation der russischen Militärexporte und wie es da eigentlich so aussieht.
Und das ist wirklich sehr interessant. Es ist immer sehr viel zu prozessieren,
wenn man sich seine Videos anschaut, weil er redet schnell und liefert irgendwie
eine Information nach der anderen. Das ist wirklich krass, aber es ist immer super erzählt.
Ich will es nur mal ganz grob zusammenfassen, weil es ist eine interessante
Perspektive und ich glaube, wir hatten das auch schon mal angedeutet.
Also Russland lebt halt vor allem vom Öl und vom Gas, gar keine Frage.
Und von petrochemischen Produkten, die halt dann refiniert werden, Benzinverkauf etc.
Das ist ja bekannt. Und das macht den Großteil der Einnahmen aus.
Auch nicht ganz unwichtig, wenn vielleicht auch nicht ansatzweise in derselben
Dimension sind die Militärexporte,
also der Verkauf von militärischem Gerät in andere Länder und das war so in
den letzten Jahrzehnten durchaus auch eine Cashcrow,
aber noch wichtiger glaube ich als...
Der eigentliche Geldfaktor, der aber auch eine Rolle spielt,
ist, dass in dem Moment, wo man natürlich Länder mit eigenem militärischen Gut
bestückt, in gewisser Hinsicht auch einen Teil der Kontrolle mit übernimmt.
Also dass man sozusagen hier auch Einfluss hat,
weil die verkaufst du ja nicht einfach einmal und dann war es das,
sondern das heißt ja du brauchst fortlaufenden Kontakt zu diesen Ländern und
hast natürlich auch in gewisser Hinsicht Einblicke auf das militärische Geschehen in diesen Ländern etc.
Und das Geld ist aber auch vor allem wichtig, um auch das eigene Militär,
beziehungsweise die Forschung und die Entwicklung dieser ganzen Militärtechnik
zu finanzieren, weil es ist teuer.
Das heißt, wenn Russland gute Jets haben will,
dann sind sie auch darauf angewiesen, dass viele Länder daran Interesse haben,
ihnen diese Jets für teuer Geld abkaufen, um einfach eine entsprechende Finanzierung
vornehmen zu können, um einfach weiterentwickeln zu können und die nächste Generation
von Kampfflugzeugen dann eben auch irgendwann am Start zu haben.
Jetzt ist es einfach so, dass aus vielen Gründen in Russland schon seit Jahren
nichts mehr geordert wurde.
Es gibt zwar Statistiken, die sagen, ja Russland hat hier letztes Jahr ja noch
so und so viel Material an China ausgeliefert und an Indien.
Das ist richtig, nur das sind alles Dinge, die schon vor ewigen Zeiten bestellt wurden.
Und mit ewig meine ich halt also teilweise über ein Jahrzehnt.
Weil irgendwann mal gesagt wurde, ja wir nehmen jetzt hier mal 10 Flieger und
die Flugabwehrsysteme etc.
Aber die kommen ja dann nicht am nächsten Tag per Amazon in Briefkasten,
sondern die müssen ja auch mal gebaut werden etc. Etc. pp.
Und mittlerweile gehen dem militärischen Komplex in Russland einfach die Aufträge aus.
Und das hat einfach auch viele Gründe.
Und der Krieg macht die Situation in gar keiner Hinsicht besser,
weil natürlich einerseits Russland derzeit auch alles selber braucht.
Also Kampfflugzeuge etc. mit der Geschwindigkeit, wie die Ukraine ihnen gerade
die Flugzeuge wegsäbelt, können die sich jetzt nicht erlauben,
die nächsten 20 Flugzeuge irgendwie nach Indien zu fliegen, sondern die brauchen
sie irgendwie alle selber.
Und auch die ganze Weiterentwicklung ist halt einfach zum Stehen gekommen.
Und da ist auch irgendwie keine Besserung in Sicht.
Und das bedeutet natürlich, dass sie auch keine technologische Verbesserung
vornehmen können, weil ihnen das Geld fehlt und der Incentive fehlt etc.
Das betrifft jetzt, deswegen Deswegen bleibe ich bei Jets auch hier als Beispiel,
vor allem in der ganzen Aviation, also der ganze Luftkampftechnikbereich.
Und zwar nicht, weil Russland nichts anderes herstellen würde,
sondern weil das, von dem sie am meisten herstellen, nämlich die Artillerie
und von dem sie auch am meisten selber haben.
Das interessiert keinen. Also Russland exportiert keine Artillerie,
sondern alles was sie dort produzieren ist eigentlich für den Eigenbedarf.
Andere Länder kaufen keine russischen Haubitzen und so weiter.
Also klar, es gibt ein paar Länder, die was haben, aber das spielt im Großen
und Ganzen keine Rolle vom Geld her etc.
So und damit fällt einfach Russland in den nächsten Jahren, das ist mal eine
ganz gute Nachricht, eine Menge Geld weg auf der einen Seite,
aber auf der anderen Seite wird es eben auch sehr schwierig werden,
diesen militärischen Komplex aufrecht zu erhalten und zu finanzieren.
Und derzeit leben die hier sozusagen alle nur von dem russischen Staatsgeld,
was halt wiederum nur aus der Petrochemie kommt und es wird schwierig werden
hier überhaupt noch eine Balance zu halten,
weil derzeit arbeiten die quasi full on für diesen Ukraine Krieg,
haben aber auch schon Probleme Personal zu bekommen für ihre Fabriken und sollte
halt in irgendeiner Form das mal zurückgefahren werden, Dann wird das eben auch
sofort in eine andere Imbalanz kommen,
weil dann gibt es halt noch nicht mal mehr die nationale Nachfrage und eine
internationale Nachfrage gibt es schon mal gar nicht.
Weil auch die Tanker, äh die Tanker, die Panzer, jetzt habe ich so oft das Wort
Tank gehört, jetzt wird aus dem Panzer ein Tanker.
Gerade so die Panzertechnik, die sie ja auch häufiger exportiert haben,
sagen wir mal zurückhaltend, beweist sich auf dem ukrainischen Schlachtfeld
nicht gerade als so besonders attraktives Gerät.
Also die Russen mit diesem riesigen Aufwand, diesen Mengen an Material,
was sie haben, sind so ineffizient, dass glaube ich es ein bisschen schwierig
wird in Zukunft auch die ganzen Militärpartner zu halten und sie haben jetzt schon sehr wenige.
Also sehr wenige Länder überhaupt haben in den letzten Jahren überhaupt noch
irgendwelche Lieferungen empfangen.
Also es sind, glaube ich, nur noch so fünf Länder und das sind halt alles so
unmittelbare Randstaaten, die halt noch unter einem Einfluss liegen.
Und auch die haben eigentlich keinen Bock mehr darauf, Russland in irgendeiner Form zu unterstützen.
Ja, ich frage mich,
Also es klingt alles sehr schlüssig und nicht gut für Russland.
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir natürlich schon gesehen,
dass bei den jetzt einfacheren Produkten, also die Artilleriegranaten,
sie jetzt sehr schnell in der Lage waren, die Produktion zu steigern und eben
wahrscheinlich auch den Output an mittelmäßigen Waffen.
Wahrscheinlich, ja, durchaus werden steigern können.
Und die Frage, die sich mir dann stellt, ist, wie viel bringt eben technologischer
Vorteil und wie viel bringt dann einfach Menge?
Ich meine, wenn Sie zweimal so viel verlieren wie die Ukrainer,
aber dreimal so viel produzieren, dann kann das am Ende, wird das zwar sehr,
sehr teuer für die Russen, aber so haben sie halt auch den Zweiten Weltkrieg
gegenüber Deutschland gewonnen,
indem sie halt einfach auch mal ein Vielfaches der Verluste von allen anderen,
inklusive auch Deutschen, Also die Russen kämpfen halt sehr,
sehr verlustreich, früher schon immer.
Und ich frage mich halt, und das ist noch nicht klar, welche Strategie am Ende...
Ja, die bessere sein wird oder sich durchsetzen wird.
Ich gehe natürlich genauso wie du davon aus, dass klüger kämpfen und sparsamer
kämpfen und intelligenter kämpfen am Ende dann doch für die Ukraine den Ausschlag geben wird.
Und ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt auch im Moment nicht vorstellen,
wie Russland das Ganze gewinnen sollte, weil wie gesagt,
sobald Russland zu erfolgreich wird, wird der Westen auch nochmal es eskalieren.
Insofern, ich sehe da kein Szenario im Moment.
Aber so grundsätzlich einerseits so erfreulich das auch ist,
dass die russischen Exporte oder das Russland als Waffenexporteur erstmal abgemeldet ist,
sollte man da nicht zu viele Konsequenzen für den weiteren Kriegsverlauf in
der Ukraine rausziehen können notwendigerweise.
Also das ist einfach nur mein Punkt, so erfreulich es auch ist. Klar.
Gut, daran schließe ich im Prinzip auch an, dass es also auch Anzeichen gibt,
dass eben die gesamte wirtschaftliche Situation brüchig ist.
Auch das, nehme ich gleich mal vorweg, ist jetzt keine Aussage im Sinne von,
okay morgen bricht da die Wirtschaft zusammen und dann ist alles vorbei und alles wird gut.
Gut, weil Wirtschaften brechen nicht von heute auf morgen zusammen.
Dafür sind diese Komplexe viel zu groß und gibt es viel zu viele Selbstheilungsprozesse,
die parallel ja auch immer mit ins Spiel kommen.
Aber es ist trotzdem halt zu beobachten, dass sie eben Schwierigkeiten haben,
bestimmte Dinge noch am Leben zu erhalten.
Also die Zahl der Insolvenzen in Russland nimmt zum Beispiel gerade dramatisch zu.
Und wir hatten vorhin schon gesprochen, dass es eben sehr schwierig ist,
diese ganzen Öl- und Gasproduktionsorte in Betrieb zu erhalten.
Einerseits, weil sie zerstört werden, aber weil teilweise eben auch einfach
schon das Businessmodell fehlt.
Also es gibt Anlass dazu, davon auszugehen, dass dieses Sanktionsregime,
was man ja immer anzweifelt mit, wird denn das was bringen und guck mal,
jetzt ist die Wirtschaft ja immer noch da und dann hat das ja alles nichts gebracht
und warum machen wir denn das überhaupt.
Das sind alles Dinge, die muss man sehr langfristig denken und konsequenter denken.
Und es zeigen sich halt jetzt auch schon erste Effekte, speziell jetzt auch
durch diese Sekundärsanktionen der Amerikaner, dass sie halt jetzt auch den Inneren klar machen,
zum Beispiel, klar könnt ihr irgendwie Öl in Russland kaufen.
Aber dann sanktionieren wir halt die Firmen, die das in Indien tun.
Und dann macht die aber mit den USA keine Geschäfte mehr. Jetzt könnt ihr mal
sehen, wie ihr das so findet.
Und das sind dann halt schon Dinge, wo man eben sieht, aha okay,
jetzt kaufen auch die Inder weniger von den Russen.
Also es wird in zunehmendem Maße schwieriger, solange man eben diesen Pfad beibehält
und das eben als einzelne weitere Komponente in diesem Krieg akzeptiert,
dass man eben sowohl wirtschaftlichen Druck macht,
Zerstörung der Infrastruktur, mit der Russland Geld verdient,
einfach um diesen Geldhahn zuzudrehen.
Weil wenn kein Geld mehr da ist, dann wird es auch sehr schwierig,
diesen Militärapparat noch aufrecht zu erhalten und irgendwann wird auch ein
Putin dann eben ans Ende der Möglichkeiten kommen,
weil du halt einfach nichts mehr kaufen kannst, dann ist es halt schwierig und
die Unzufriedenheit in der Bevölkerung ist nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Ja, also mein Eindruck, was jetzt so die normale Bevölkerung angeht, ist der,
es gibt nach wie vor alles zu kaufen, von gelegentlichen regionalen Ausnahmen
mal abgesehen, wo es dann so eine Eier- und Hühnerfleischknappheit gab.
Ja, aber ansonsten grundsätzlich kriegst du auch das neueste iPhone dort.
Nur es ist teurer geworden.
Es ist alles überproportional teurer geworden,
weil eben auch durch die Sanktionen es jetzt mehr Mittelsleute gibt,
gibt, die bezahlt werden wollen,
was so jetzt gerade Westprodukte angeht.
Dann eben schon bestimmte Knappheiten sich ja auch in bestimmten Bereichen,
aber grundsätzlich, glaube ich, fühlt sich das für den normalen Russen so an,
als sei alles deutlich teuer geworden.
Vor allem ausländische Produkte sind nochmal überproportional angezogen.
Aber größere Versorgungsengpässe gibt es nicht. Die Leute können sich nur weniger leisten.
Ja und teilweise springt halt China ein, also so Autos, Westautos gibt es ja
auch nicht mehr so richtig.
Das heißt, die kaufen jetzt alle chinesische Autos, aber damit sind sie wohl
nicht besonders glücklich.
Also sie merken halt schon, dass sich da Dinge ändern, das Haushaltsdefizit
wächst unheilsam an und da muss einfach der Druck muss beibehalten werden und dann wird es auch was.
So, jetzt sind wir eigentlich schon am Ende unserer Themenliste. Schon ist gut.
Wir haben jetzt die Hälfte der Länge der letzten Sendung.
Vielleicht noch zwei, drei Kleinigkeiten und ein paar Tipps für euch auch zum Schauen,
wo man sich nochmal ganz interessant sowohl über die Geschichte der Ukraine
als auch die Geschichte Russlands nochmal informieren kann.
Also was mir sehr viel geholfen hat, ist ein Beitrag auf Arte,
der heißt Black Box Ukraine, Kampf um die Geschichte.
Und das ist wirklich eine sehr schöne Zusammenfassung der Geschichte der Ukraine
selbst. Also wirklich, wie dieses Land über die Jahrhunderte entstanden ist.
Diese Kiew war Russ etc.
Also Kiew gab es schon vor Moskau. Also dieser ganze Propagandaturn der Russen,
dass die Ukraine ja schon immer russisch gewesen sei,
das scheitert schon daran, dass es halt irgendwie das Russland nicht gab.
Und dass sogar der Begriff Russ eigentlich aus der Ukraine kommt,
aber nicht weil es russisch ist, sondern weil sich das Russland angeeignet hat.
Sehr interessant auf jeden Fall. Und ein zweiter Beitrag ist von YouTube vom Icarus Projekt,
was eben das Verhältnis von Russland zu seinem ostasiatischen Teil erläutert
und warum Sibirien aus Russland austreten möchte.
Auch ein sehr interessanter Flug durch die Geschichte, der glaube ich nochmal
einiges klar macht, auch was sozusagen die Mongolen und Genghis Khan mit dem
heutigen Russland zu tun haben,
dem Raubbau, den die Russen dann im Osten begangen haben und wie sie auch schon
vor Jahrhunderten die Völker im Osten durch False Flag Aktionen kontrolliert haben.
Und leider auch sehr viel von dieser Grausamkeit, die die Mongolen wiederum
über die Welt gebracht haben, dann inkorporiert haben in ihre eigenen Methodiken.
Kann ich also sehr empfehlen, diese beiden Videos.
Und dann als allerletztes hast
du mitbekommen, dass das Auswärtige Amt die offizielle Schreibung von Kiew,
geändert hat also bisher.
Bisher,
hat man ja diese Stadt in Deutsch Kiew genannt und geschrieben K-I-E-W,
und das ist im Prinzip die russische Art und Weise diese Stadt zu beschreiben.
Also Kiew ist sozusagen wie ein Russe das sagen würde.
Und da ich auch drauf angesprochen wurde, Oder im letzten Podcast,
weil ich halt Kiew gesagt habe, warum ich es denn falsch aussprechen würde,
wird das nochmal aufgebracht.
Das ist nämlich jetzt geändert worden.
Die Schreibung, die offizielle Schreibung des Städtenamens, so wie es jetzt
das Außenministerium handhabt in Deutschland, ist Kiew. Yiv.
Und wenn man sich halt die kyrillische Schreibung des Städtenamens anschaut.
Dann ist es ja sind es vier Buchstaben, du hast halt erstmal dieses spiegelverkehrte
N, jetzt aus unserer Perspektive, und dann ein I mit Trema.
Und das sind halt zwei zwei verschiedene I-Laute im Ukrainischen.
Während das umgedrehte N halt eigentlich unserem normalen I entspricht,
ist halt dieses I mit Trema so ein J-Sound.
Das heißt, korrekt ausgesprochen heißt die Stadt Kijiv.
Nur dass das halt, wenn man schnell spricht, schnell zum Kiv wird.
Aber dieses Kijiv F ist sozusagen die russische Variante.
Im Fall von Odessa, wo sich die Ukraine ein bisschen daran stört,
dass Deutschland Odessa mit Doppel-S schreibt, was auch wiederum die russische
Variante ist, aber es sich in dem ukrainischen eben nur Odessa mit einem S sozusagen,
also in dem Fall ein C-Glyph, was halt das im kyrillischen eben das ist,
ist die Argumentation des Außenministeriums dass wenn man das jetzt machen würde
dann würden halt alle Odesa sagen das kann ich auch nachvollziehen aber Kiev oder Kief.
In der englischen Transliteration ist es ja eben dieses,
Kiew mit V und man sagt halt Kief und das hängt alles immer davon ab,
in welche Sprache du das transkribierst etc.
In der Ukraine ist ja alles irgendwie in dieser englischen Transkription gehalten
oder Transliteration gehalten,
das heißt du hast immer das Original in der kyrillischen Schreibung und darunter
hast du eben dann auch nochmal eine Übersetzung eben aber in dieser englischen Transliteration.
Ja, ich habe es mir ganz einfach gemacht. Ich habe versucht,
das so auszusprechen, wie Marina Weisband das ausgesprochen hat, weil die kommt von da.
Und die hat irgendwie Kiew gesagt und deswegen habe ich dann das einfach übernommen,
weil ich mir dachte, das kann jetzt nicht verkehrt sein.
Und es gibt bestimmt Gründe, warum sie nicht Kiew sagt, sondern Kiew.
Und ich dachte mir dann, ja, mache ich das auch so.
Genau, und das ist auch richtig so und jetzt wollte ich nur mal erläutern,
warum das eigentlich so ist.
Ja, und ich finde das aber sehr interessant, jetzt zu wissen, was dahinter steckt.
Mein Grund ein sehr simpler war.
Ja, das war es dann auch von uns.
Mal noch eine Vorhersage wagen, wie das jetzt so weitergeht.
Ja, was hast du denn so an Vorhersagen angeboten?
Ja, ich würde sagen, die von vor zwei Sendungen ist nach wie vor unverändert,
nämlich, dass es erst noch schlimmer kommen wird, bevor es besser wird.
Und das, ja, irgendwann...
Dass die Russen vielleicht mehr Fortschritte noch machen werden und die Situation
der Ukraine noch prekärer sein wird und dass dann aber der Westen ein bisschen mehr aufwacht.
Und dann ist ja immer noch, ja, was passiert mit der USA?
Das ist so ein bisschen das Entscheidende.
Und das lässt sich nur schwer vorhersagen.
Im Moment liegt Trump ja in den Umfragen vorn.
Und auch wenn ich nicht glaube, dass er gewinnen wird und das auch nicht hoffe,
führt das eben zu der aktuellen Lähmungssituation.
Also was jetzt in einem halben Jahr passiert, steht auf einem Blatt.
Aber sagen, was jetzt die Demokraten in der Lage sind zu tun oder was die amerikanische
Politik jetzt in der Lage ist zu tun oder nicht zu tun, hängt halt eben auch
stark mit diesen Umfragen gerade zusammen.
Und das macht das alles etwas unschön in den Blick auf die Zukunft.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Russland am Ende irgendwie irgendwas gewinnen wird,
aber es ist nach wie vor kein Ende in Sicht und es wird für die Ukraine auch
erstmal nicht so toll werden, der Sommer wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich, das ist meine Einschätzung und Befürchtung und auch wir werden
irgendwann Schlagzeilen hier sehen, die dann dazu führen werden,
dass vielleicht hier ein bisschen mehr dann Einsicht in die Notwendigkeit bestehen
wird, dass wir uns da nicht so weit zurücklehnen können, wie wir das manchmal tun.
Ja und das ist ja auch, das darf man nicht vergessen.
Das ist nicht nur eine Einschränkung für die Ukraine im Sinne von,
oh jetzt haben wir immer noch Krieg, sondern das schränkt uns auch ein.
Nein, es hindert uns daran unser Sicherheitssystem aufzubauen,
es hindert uns auch daran die Ukraine in die NATO aufzunehmen,
die Ukraine in die EU aufzunehmen, Moldawien in die EU aufzunehmen,
um an der Stelle einfach auch so ein weiteres Friedensgerüst zu schaffen.
Und deswegen wäre es schon gut zu sehen, dass sich nicht nur die europäische,
sondern auch die US-amerikanische Politik ändert.
Und zwar jetzt nicht nur im Hinblick auf Trump, sondern auch die Demokraten
sind sehr zögerlich. Also ich meine, sie hätten die Möglichkeit gehabt,
sehr viel mehr Waffen zu liefern, sehr viel mehr Panzer zu liefern.
Sie hätten all in gehen können, gleich von Anfang an und alles das,
was jetzt nicht geliefert werden konnte,
weil die Blockade der Republikaner aufgebaut wurde, hätte auch schon geliefert
werden können, als es diese Blockade noch nicht gab. Und zwar ohne Not.
Also die haben da genug Zeug rumliegen, das hätten die Amerikaner locker aus
ihrem Lager alles liefern können.
Da ist so viel Munition, die sowieso weggeworfen wird.
Das hätte man alles liefern können. Man hätte Attackams liefern können,
die halt mehr als 300 Kilometer fliegen und dann werden viele Militärbasen der
Russen längst schon zerstört.
Aber das sind halt alles Dinge, die gelassen wurden und man hat halt Zeit verstreichen
lassen und jetzt sich in diese Wahlkampfwirren begeben so und bevor halt.
Dieses Trump-Debakel nicht abgewendet ist, wird sich unter Umständen gar nichts tun.
Also es kann sehr gut sein, dass wir wirklich bis zum Herbst keinerlei Unterstützung
der Amerikaner sehen und das bedeutet, dass halt einfach Europa jetzt sein Game
finden muss und dort entsprechend,
Maßnahmen ergreifen muss, weil wenn diese Maßnahmen nicht ergriffen,
werden, ich meine, wir gehen alle davon aus, dass Russland am Ende gestoppt werden werden muss.
Das wird jetzt immer teurer. Und es wird vor allem immer teurer,
die Ukraine danach zu reparieren.
Irgendwann werden wir sie in die EU aufnehmen. Wir werden selbstverständlich
der Ukraine eine Art Marschallplan liefern müssen, um dieses Land von Grund
auf wieder in seiner Infrastruktur herzustellen.
Das wird jetzt jeden Tag teurer.
Also jede Hilfe heute ist um ein Zehnfaches billiger als als die Beseitigung der Schäden.
Und da rede ich mal gar nicht von dem psychologischen Traumata,
die das alles noch nach sich ziehen wird.
Insofern, get working on it.
Ja, ja. Und China und Indien lobbyieren gerade die Bundesregierung,
den Russen doch nicht das Geld wegzunehmen, die 200 Milliarden nicht zu Beschlagnahmen,
um die in die Ukraine umzulenken.
Aber schauen wir mal, wo das hingeht.
Die Diktatoren der Welt irgendwie fürchten jetzt um ihr Geld.
Gut, Leute, das war's.
Wir melden uns wieder, wenn was ist, vielleicht so in einem Monat oder so.
Wir beobachten weiterhin die Situation und dann melden wir uns wieder und fassen.
Das gerne für euch zusammen. wir freuen uns auf eure kommentare sagen tschüss und bis bald macht's gut.